[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette première séance de questions
d'actualité de l'année je vous souhaite
une très belle année 2020 elle s'annonce
riche en actualités parlementaire et ça
commence aujourd'hui avec une séance de
questions largement consacrée à la
réforme des retraites on va en parler
avec nos journalistes quand un calme est
dans l'hémicycle du sénat et alexandre
poussard salle des conférences
notez que hier déjà les sénateurs ont
débattu de la réforme avec le nouveau
secrétaire d'état laurent pietrasinski
ses réponses les ont laissés sur leur
faim
la tension monte entre l'iran et les
états unis
cette nuit téhéran a tiré des missiles
sur deux bases utilisées par l'armée
américaine en irak
une riposte après l'assassinât du
général soliman y par les états unis la
semaine dernière
on en débat à 14h30 enfin carlos ghosn
s'explique l'ancien patron de l'alliance
renault nissan donne cet après midi une
conférence de presse après sa fuite la
semaine dernière du japon pour le liban
réactions dans cette émission
et n'hésitez pas à réagir et à commenter
cette émission avec le hashtag qu à g et
on va tout de suite rejoindre quand un
calme est dans l'hémicycle du sénat
bonjour quand un très belle année à vous
dans une heure maintenant vous commencez
les questions d'actu alors comment ça va
se passer
et quelles vont être les temps forts de
cette séance oui bonjour tam très bonne
année à vous également et au programme
de ces toutes premières questions
d'actualité de l'année 2020 il bien lieu
il ya trois sujets majeurs dont deux que
vous avez déjà évoqué dans les titres de
votre émission
le premier c'est celui bien sûr des
retraites avec au moins quatre questions
venues de quatre groupes politiques
différents sur le sujet de la réforme
des retraites est on le sait un des
questions au lendemain d'un débat au
sénat sur la réforme et ou irl et les
groupes se sont montrés est très
critiqué en parlant d' incohérences et
de manque de pédagogie sur les bancs de
la droite ou encore d'une gestion
chaotique du dossier selon les
centristes ou encore d'un projet à
l'impact incontrôlés ont pu dire les
socialistes deuxième sujet à la une
aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr cette
escalade des tensions entre les
etats-unis et l'iran au moins deux
questions venues des communistes et des
centristes vont porter sur ce sujet
enfin troisième thème à la une
aujourd'hui avec deux questions
d'actualité et bien c'est sur cette
décision le 19 décembre dernier de la
cour d'appel de paris de déclarer qu
billy traoré mis en examen pour le
meurtre de sarah halimi pénalement
irresponsable on va voir donc deux
questions sur ce sujet aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup quentin pour toutes ces
précisions
et vous l'avez dit les retraites seront
donc au menu de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
le sujet a aussi été débattu hier dans
l'hémicycle en présence de laurent
pietrasinski le nouveau secrétaire
d'état aux retraites
hélas pris la succession de jean paul
delevoye il ya trois semaines premier
grand oral compliqué pour le nouveau
membre du gouvernement hier fanara caire
pendant près de deux heures lors
empiétera chef qui a subi le feu croisé
de la droite et de la gauche et
plusieurs fois semblé dépassée exemple
quand le sénateur et l'air rené paul
savary propose de calculer l'effet d'une
retraite à points sur les carrières
écoulée au régime actuel afin de faire
des comparaisons
si on se dit que le dispositif
doit évoluer parce que la société évolue
du coup c'est difficile de répondre à
votre question en matière de comparaison
vous me rassurez pas là monsieur le
ministre si vous me dites qu'on n'est
pas capable de faire des simulations sur
des cahiers repasser comment peut-on
être capable de faire des simulations
sur des carrières à venir à des
sénateurs pas plus rassurés quant aux
conséquences de la réforme pour les
femmes sur l'accès des veuves à leur
pension de réversion ou sur le cas des
femmes fonctionnaires les questions de
la sénatrice socialiste laurence
rossignol sont précises les réponses
évasives
ça fait partie des éléments qui doivent
être regardées encore il y a des
gagnants et des perdants pressons le
gant mais il ne peut pas y avoir que des
perdants dans le cas que vous citez
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez pas
bien compris ma question je n'ai pas pas
et des perdants j'ai parlé des perdantes
c'est à dire des femmes de cette fameuse
grande cause du quinquennat cette grande
cause qui est en train de s'effondrer
dans votre réforme des retraites
et quand on interpelle sur la retraite
des sportifs professionnels
laurent pietra chez ce qui doit
reconnaître qu'il ne maîtrise pas encore
tous les détails du dossier
c'est un sujet que je travaille avec ma
collègue roxana maracineanu et sur
lequel on est on est au démarrage à
excuser moi je suis là depuis trois
semaines j'ai essayé de travailler tous
les sujets exercice difficile donc pour
le nouveau monsieur retraites du
gouvernement
alors que la réforme doit être présentée
en conseil des ministres dans deux
semaines à 2020 commençons donc avec le
sujet qui a marqué la fin 2010 9,1 cette
fameuse réforme des retraites on va en
débattre tout de suite avec quatre
invités sur ce plateau jeu le plaisir
d'accueillir sylvie vermeillet bonjour
vous êtes à sénatrice us et du jura
membre de la commission des finances et
du conseil d'orientation des retraites
le cor dont on a beaucoup parlé depuis
le début les discussions autour des
retraites également sur ce plateau
philippe dallier bonjour un jour vous
êtes sénateur et l'air de la seine saint
denis vice président du sénat et membre
de la commission des finances également
avec nous daniel chasse un bonjour
daniel chassaing vous êtes sénateur les
indépendants de la corrèze vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et enfin sur ce plateau jeux
plaisir d'accueillir olivier d'avoise
bonjour vous êtes secrétaire général cgt
ratp bus
ce lieu est tout d'abord eh bien nous
allons
un petit peu de ce premier grand oral de
laurent pietrasinski et du débat hier
sur les retraites
daniel chassaing laurent petraeus qui
était-il hier à la hauteur il a
plusieurs fois dit on l'a entendue dans
le reportage à l'instantané ricker qui
n'avaient pas réponse à tout qu'il était
en poste depuis trois semaines c'est un
petit peu compliqué dans le contexte
non c'est vrai que hier il a répondu
parfois un petit peu évasivement est
donc bon mais on peut peut-être trop le
comprendre parce qu'il est il vient
d'arriver au ministère mais il faut que
rapidement avec son équipe il se met
dans le bain pour essayer avec les
partenaires sociaux de résoudre ce
problème et qu'il y ait dans près de
travail plus tôt possible
oui c'est l'hiver mais avoue qu'il avait
également interrogé hier comment avez
vous trouvé le nouveau secrétaire d'état
est ce que ça ne montre pas que
finalement c'est vraiment un grand
philippe qui est à la manoeuvre et
finalement leurs emplettes raser ce qui
reste quand même quelques mètres
derrière
oui cependant c'est au ministre c'est le
ministre qu'on a entendu hier on a pu
lui poser des questions mais on n'a pas
eu beaucoup de réponses et la période
est suffisamment tendue pour estimer que
le ministre n'a pas beaucoup de droit à
l'erreur donc on reste sur notre faim
oui à philippe dallier ask cette
situation vous inquiète notamment hier
lorsque certains parlementaires ont
tenté de prendre des cas précis qu'il
s'agisse de cas précis présent ou deux
cas précis dans le simulateur qui a été
mise en ligne par le gouvernement eh
bien il était d'à compliqué d'y voir
clair
quand on rentre dans le détail nous
n'avons pas de réponse mais c'est même
pire que ça puisque moi j'ai interrogé
le ministre sur l'impact budgétaire quel
est le problème de financement qui est
posée à brève échéance puisque en 2025
le corps nous dit que on a un
déséquilibre mais après il ya la réforme
avec deux phases une phase pendant
laquelle on m'avait système qui
convergent et une phase ultérieure
j'ai simplement demandé au ministre
quelle est l enjeu budgétaire
incapable de me répond à raconter ça
fait deux ans et demi que le
gouvernement travaille sur le sujet le
ministre en charge n'est pas capable de
répondre à cette simple question
pas plus d'ailleurs que le premier
ministre que j'avais interrogé lors des
questions d'actualité au mois dé
sambre ne m'a répondu donc on a on veut
effectivement faire cette réforme qui
bouleverse tous et le gouvernement est
même incapable de nous dire quels enjeux
budgétaires avant même que les syndicats
et le gouvernement ne discutent pour
savoir comment régler le problème
donc je ne sais pas où on va et on nous
dit que le 24 janvier s'attirant
quelques jours le gouvernement dépose le
projet de loi et le ministre me renvoie
à une étude d'impact qui doit
normalement accompagner ce projet de loi
et il est pas capable de m'en dire un
mot en séance
écoutez moi je ne je n'ai jamais vu une
réforme aussi importante traité de cette
manière là et le parlement aussi peu
considéré parce que les parlementaires
qui vont voter la loi
on compte même le droit de le faire en
connaissance de cause et nous n'avons
même pas idée des enjeux budgétaires
c'est hallucinant sachant que le texte
en plus on le sait a déjà été envoyée au
conseil 17 secondes
le texte est quand même l'étude d'impact
a dû être envoyé également ministre en
séance hier n'est pas capable d'en dire
deux mots
alors moi je demande à comprendre olive
et d'avoir ce qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire vous cette situation alors la
cgt depuis le début et pour le retrait
total de ce projet de loi
mais qu'est ce que vous pensez et bien
de cette situation qui il est vrai
montre une certaine impréparation
on est dans la confusion politique la
plus totale si ce n'est le fait que
selon nous selon la cgt je pense que ça
a été dit je suis pas le premier
c'est un c'est une cette réforme est une
réforme bien plus idéologique
qu'économique
le budget de la sécurité sociale toutes
branches confondues c'est quelque chose
d'énorme
c'est c'est une à peu près 1,3 fois le
budget de l'état c'est quelque chose qui
échappe
à toutes les caisses de finance bank
système d'assurance et autres
et depuis que la sécurité sociale a été
créé c'est à dire depuis 1945
ces structures financières ne rêve que
d'une chose c'est de mettre la main là
dessus donc pour moi ça ça la maladresse
de qui a été mené sur cette réforme par
l'équipe ii makoun voulait dire que ça
prépare une réforme de cette association
qu'on arrive on va mettre de côté le
système la solidarité
intergénérationnelle et par répartition
avec la garantie des droits qui elle
même va être mal et elle même menacée
dans l'état actuel des choses en tout
cas et derrière il y as cette ambition
l'idéologique de récupérer quelque chose
qui rapporterait des milliards à ce
maquis ça n'est pas destiné au départ
votre réaction arrivant de leur honda a
parlé à ce propos là il a parlé de faits
que nous disons que le texte ne préparez
donc là je crois que on peut être contre
cette réforme mais ne pas dire des
contrevérités c'est vrai que c'est bien
un régime universel par poids et par
répartition et non pas du tout par
capitalisation et étatiques et qui reste
cris veut être qui veut être qu'il va
être mis en place avec cette réforme
donc ça c'est très clair il faut on peut
être contre la réforme mais ne pas dire
si vous voulez ce qui n'existe pas
puisque c'est bien par répartition
jusqu'à 120 mille euros de personnes qui
perçoivent un salaire de 120 mille euros
au dessus
les personnes qui auront cotisé à 2,8
pour cent pour la solidarité
mais je rappelle que les personnes qui
ont un salaire de plus de 100 à 1000
euros c'est moins de 1% des salariés 1
donc c'est bien par répartition mais
parce qu'on entend aussi dans les
craintes des uns et des autres c'est que
cette réforme prépare aussi une baisse
des pensions est ce qui fait penser à
certains que donc il faudrait préparer
une retraite par capitalisation au moins
à côté pour pouvoir y pensions
bon ça je sais pas je il est quand même
toujours été dit que 14% du pib' allait
rester au niveau des retraites et donc
le produit intérieur brut
on peut voir il n'a jamais diminué il a
toujours augmenté heureusement
d'ailleurs depuis toujours
en 2000 il devait être autour de 15
cents là il est à 2006 cinq ou six ans
je ne sais plus donc à partir du moment
où on garde 14% du pipe je rappelle que
ces 10% en allemagne ça veut dire que
globalement les retraites ne vont pas
diminuer 14% du pied parce que c'est une
garantie pour que et bien les retraités
et suffisamment de retraite sylvie
vermeillet si on considère ce que l'on
dit souvent qu'il y aura peut-être de
plus en plus de retraités oui le
problème c'est à quel moment parce que
il ya quand même l'élément démographique
qui s'impose à nous et le l'arrivée en
retraite de la classe du papy-boom fait
que on a une phase difficile à passer
et est ce qu'il faudrait que ça soit
plus que 14% si on pense à cette phase
de papy bon bah je pense que 14% du pipe
c'est déjà pas mal c'est des jeunes
c'est une sécurité on est à 13,6
actuellement c'est déjà pas mal mais il
faut être capable aussi d'observer cet
effet démographique et on a à subir on
est en train de rentrer dans la phase où
la classe du papy-boom arrive en
retraite donc ça fait des pensions
supérieures à honorer mais je voudrais
quand même faire observer sur les
projections du cor qu'une fois que la
génération du papy boom a disparu on
retrouve un excédent avec un minimum de
croissance du pif c'est normal mais
c'est quand même quelque chose dont
j'entends absolument pas parlé je
voudrais ajouter quand même que les
pensions effectivement ne diminue pas
mais le taux de rendement des pensions
relatif ne cesse de diminuer c'est à
dire que je ne suis pas partisane de
charger la classe active actuelle cette
classe active actuelle elle a jamais
autant cotiser sur une base aussi large
et l'a jamais cotisé aussi longtemps
parce que c'est l'effort maximum pour un
taux de rendement de sa pension qui est
toujours inférieur donc il faut faire
attention quand on dit on va reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite ou alors
on va augmenter le taux de cotisation
il faut regarder la soutenabilité de
cette réforme est ce que la classe
actifs d'aujourd'hui est capable de
pouvoir encaisser plus c'est difficile
alors vous avez tout de suite soulevé la
question du financement philippe dallier
que pensez vous et bien de la
proposition de la cfdt d'organiser une
conférence de financement c'est une
proposition que le gouvernement a
directement saisi ce qu'on peut attendre
cela pour vous une sortie de crise je
rappelle que la conférence a décidé on
sait qu'il aura fallu attendre d'être en
janvier 2020 pour que la proposition
soit faite et venant en plus d'un
syndicat et pas du gouvernement et en
impression que le premier mis ses
précipiter là dessus d'ailleurs pour
renouer le dialogue avec la cfdt
mais on a l'impression que c'est
seulement maintenant qu'on va
s'inquiéter du fait de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on va équilibrer le système
assez incroyable dire que ça se
travaille là il aurait dû être fait au
préalable
quand on veut essayer de résoudre une
équation essayer d'abord de poser
problème et après on cherche des
solutions mais l'impression qu'ils ont
fait tout le contraire
maintenant pour revenir sur ce qui était
dit cette réforme c'est d'abord une
force formidable processus d'étatisation
du système des retraites c'est pas du
tout une privatisation
et d'ailleurs ce qui va se passer c'est
que le gouvernement le nouveau système
va capter ou en tous les cas c'était
l'intention à l'origine tous ceux qui se
trouvent aujourd'hui dans les caisses
complémentaires et cette réforme c'est
la disparition des caisses
complémentaires au profit d'un système
universel et c'est une des questions qui
se posent les réserves de l'agirc-arrco
des salariés qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et
puis il ya toutes les caisses autonomes
c'est ça aussi la véritable question
donc c'est d'abord une étatisation mais
dans un deuxième temps est-ce qu'elle ne
poussera pas justement parce que ce
système va soulever des craintes
est ce qu'elle ne va pas pousser
certains et notamment les hauts revenus
puisqu'il ne cotiseront plus à aller
vers un système de par capitalisation
bien évidemment que oui mais dans un
premier temps c'est une formidable
entreprise d'étatisation est ce que je
veux savoir c'est comment le
gouvernement compte utiliser les
réserves de l'agirc arrco et des autres
parce que jusqu'à présent nous on nous
dit ça va être formidable un système
plus juste plus équitable très bien qui
garantit les pensions à l'avenir ça j'en
suis beaucoup moins certain parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un système quand les
gens partent à leur tête ils savent
combien ivoire
ils savent comment ces calculs et les 25
meilleures années pour les
fonctionnaires c'est différent mais avec
le nouveau système on vous donne des
points et on vous dit le point ne
baissera pas dans dix ans dans 20 ans
mais personne n'en sait rien qui peut
donner cette garantie à vie personne
donc aujourd'hui vous avez un mode de
calcul des retraites qui est compris par
les français
le nouveau ils vous donnent des points
mais la suite est bien ça dépendra de la
conjoncture des gouvernements et est
donc là il ya une inquiétude et je la
comprends cette inquiétude est la base
vous entendez philippe dallier ils
disent aussi une façon de mettre d'avoir
la mainmise sur les caisses de l'agirc
arrco qui pour l'instant est géré par
les partenaires sociaux
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ils vont
disparaître ben ça n'inspire beaucoup de
crainte lorsque pourquoi ça aspire
beaucoup de craintes et logique
les retraites c'est les cotisations
sociales voilà c'est le salaire c'est de
l'argent gagné par le travail ça
appartient aux salariés dans la fiche de
paye vous avez plusieurs colonnes vous
avez les cotisations sociales salariales
et les cotisations sociales patronales
tout ça ça fait tout ça fait le salaire
ce que moi j'appelle de salaire global
qui ce qui est au dessus du salaire brut
tout ça c'est du salaire c'est dégagé
par la richesse produite par le travail
oh là moi quand monsieur dalil me dit va
dit que c'est une formidable étatisation
du système
ben moi ça me fait froid dans le dos
c'est ça veut dire que l'état nous pique
votre pognon quoi ne pas dire autre
chose et ça sent les parties nice
baptisation alors certains pourraient
sans rassurer
abba cissé étatique ça va tout va bien
il ya des garanties c'est démocratique
machin et tout ça ok bon d'accord je
veux bien l'entendre
enfin ça ne pourrait être qu'une étape
avant une véritable privatisation
parce que depuis une trentaine d'années
les privatisations c'est à la mode quand
mes mains
le conseil devrait donc moi quand
monsieur ce que vient de dire monsieur
d'allier ça me rassure pas du tout et ça
me donne pas du tout envie de reprendre
le bout de bois the way you lie qui n'a
pas du tout été rassurés hier lors du
débat c'est laurence rossignol la
sénatrice socialiste à votre micro
alexandre et hier elle a également
interrogé le gouvernement lors de ce
débat sur les retraites
et oui laurence rossignol vous avez
interrogé le gouvernement hier notamment
sur les grandes perdantes de cette
réforme les femmes divorcées et vous
n'avez pas si vous n'avez pas été
satisfaites par les réponses apportées
j'ai posé plusieurs questions au
secrétaire d'état qui était présent hier
je vais demander d'abord
la pension de reversions continuera
d'être versée dès 55 ans comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
ou si comme on l'a beaucoup entendu dire
elles seraient désormais versées qu'à
partir de 64 ans j'ai posé la question
des femmes divorcées qui serait
désormais dans la réforme
exclu du bénéfice de la pension de
reversions et j'ai attiré l'attention du
secrétaire d'état sur le fait que
lorsqu'une femme n'avait pas travaillé
pendant ou peu travaillé pendant 25 ans
parce qu'elle avait élevé les enfants du
couple et qu'elle se retrouvait à
divorcer tardivement
comment allaiter le vivre
si on lui retire sa pension de
reversions ce qui était pour demander
mais damage modeste le seul revenu
qu'ont les femmes
et puis ensuite je pose aussi la
question ce constat un passant en
version si on ne craignait pas que en
supprimant la pension de reversions aux
femmes qui divorceraient on accroissent
leur dépendance économique à l'égard de
leurs conjoints et je pense en
particulier aux femmes victimes de
violences conjugales déjà partir suppose
s'organiser suppose avoir des ressources
mais si en plus partir veut dire une
vieillesse dans la pauvreté
c'est sûr que ça ne va pas inciter les
femmes à quitter les conjoints violents
je n'ai aucune réponse j'ai posé la
question également sur la manière dont
les femmes fonctionnaires qui sont 62%
des fonctionnaires sont des femmes
allez voir leur pension de vieillesse
baissée et j'ai demandé mais comment
est-ce possible que cette fameuse grande
cause du quinquennat qu'est l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
s'effondrent comme elle le fait
aujourd'hui sur la réforme des retraites
je n'ai eu aucune réponse de la
secrétaire d'état
je ne sais pas c'était de l'incompétence
de la négligence du mépris du parlement
mais ils ne savaient répondre à aucune
de mes questions qui était pourtant
simple et qui en plus sont dans le débat
depuis je crois deux ans parce qu'il a
quand même ce garçon a hérité des
dossiers de le voit la question de l'âge
de personnes des pensions de réversion
est posée la question des femmes
divorcées et poser est donc il n'avait
aucune réponse à apporter
j'étais accablé par la faiblesse la
fragilité de ce secrétaire d'état et
surtout par l'amateurisme
l'impréparation de ce gouvernement qui
visiblement dans cette réforme des
retraites à deux trois totems qui
l'agitent afin de d'agitation politique
et mais qui en réalise
des navires totalement à vue et ne sait
pas comment il va passer la journée de
demain
c'est de l'amateurisme ou c certaines
informations qui sont cachés pour ne pas
allumer les braises politique c'est les
deux mais ceci dit caché des
informations ça peut marcher que pendant
un temps il va bien falloir que le
projet de loi soit connue qui va sortir
du conseil d'état comment dire quand le
même jour là c'est d'ailleurs d'état
chargé de la porte parole du
gouvernement dit que rien n'est décidé
et que le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations que parlement dit que le
projet est transmis au conseil d'état
qui croire probablement le deuxième
parce que c'est factuel le fait d'avoir
transmis le projet de loi au conseil
d'état mais ce gouvernement semble mal
communiqué en son sein et surtout nous
donne l'impression d'être tout en train
d'essayer de nous rouler dans la farine
en fait de nous de décider de nous
manipuler et après ils s'étonnent que
les français soient inquiets de leurs
réformes
ils font tout pour que les français
soient inquiets de cette réforme et les
français ont bien raison d'être inquiet
de cette réforme
ce ne sont pas eux qui sont sains qui
sont inconsidérément
pour eux c'est le gouvernement qui
prépare des mauvais coups contre les
retraites très bien merci beaucoup
laurence rossignol pour vos réponses
répondez vous daniel chassaing le
gouvernement qui prépare des mauvais
coups contre les retraites elle prend le
cas apprécié par les femmes divorcées je
suis d'accord bombes et les pensions de
réversion je n'ai pas vu dans le dossier
que les pensions de réversion lettres
supprimer jouer quand même dire ne pas
être aussi pessimiste que madame
rossignol je rappelle que la loi
touraine ont quand même 43% de 43 ans de
cotisations donc moi je pense que cette
réforme est bien apporte des plus alors
je suis d'accord avec philippe dallier
qui nie le financement n'est pas réglée
mais il ya quand même des projets qui
sont intéressants à savoir 1000 euros
pour les personnes en retraite minimum
1000 euros c'est avec dans les ruraux
des artisans les agriculteurs n'ont
malheureusement pas les 1000 euros
je rappelle que ce sera quand même
gouverné par les partenaires sociaux en
ce ce projet cette loi est aussi
la pénibilité va être quand même étendue
au niveau du haut niveau des hôpitaux et
au niveau également de la fonction
publique et donc bien sûr avec des cas
particuliers donc globalement si on a
des inconnus c'est le financement mais
en tout cas si oui mais je suis là quand
même le maire de connu il faut
absolument le préciser qu'ils aient des
simulations mais il n'y a pas de raison
que ce soit un régime qui soit aussi
mauvais que tout le monde le dit mais
moi je ne veux pas faire de procès
d'intention gouvernement je suis
incapable de dire si cette réforme va
être bonne ou mauvaise je ne sais même
pas ce qu'il ya dedans
ce qui est quand même un comble pour un
parlementaire membre de la commission
des finances
je suis incapable de le détailler
aujourd'hui donc j'entends le
gouvernement qui répète à l'envi comme
ça ça sera plus juste plus juste plus
juste mais bon me sens quand nous le
démontre et s'il s'agissait de
revaloriser à 1000 euros minimum toutes
les pensions mais on n'a pas besoin de
casser tout système actuel pour le faire
je rappelle déjà que pour les
agriculteurs le sénat avait voté à
l'unanimité ici l'année dernière à la
revalorisation des pensions le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu ça coûtait
400 millions d'euros par an il n'en a
pas voulu
donc si on voulait faire des gestes
effectivement sur la pénibilité pour
ceux qui ont de petites pensions pour
les carrières hachées etc
on pouvait le faire dans le système
actuel alors c'est pas de ça quand il
s'agit on nous vend un grand
bouleversement avec un régime universel
qui est de moins en moins universel
puisque on est en train d'en sortir
petit à petit toute une catégorie
donc au bout du compte qu'est ce qui va
rester est pas uniforme donc a peut être
oui mais il ya aussi des poissons
volants mais c'est pas là
tout ça ils peuvent pas partir en lui
c'est parce qu'on nous a vendu au départ
c'est là où les français n'y comprennent
plus c'est qu'entre ce qu'on nous a dit
en 2025 un régime unique pour tout le
monde et ce qui est en train de se
profiler
c'est le jour et la nuit et par dessus
le marché personne n'est capable de nous
dire ce que ça coûte et qui sera impacté
sylvie vermeillet oui pour vous la
sortie de plus parce que au-delà de tous
les problèmes que vous soulevez
actuellement on sent aussi le la
négociation qui est en train de se
passer entre le gouvernement et la cfdt
les débats qui peut y avoir aussi sur
l'âge qui vaut à 64 ans en asie par
exemple cette proposition de richard
ferrand début de semaine qui dit bon bah
finalement on pourrait conserver cet âge
pivot mais avec un malus qui pourrait
être seulement temporaire s'appliquer
pendant deux trois ans on le regardait
c'était dans les colonnes du parisien
en ce début de semaine on sent quand
même que le gouvernement est en train de
bouger pour vous là dessus écoutez pour
moi en tant que sénatrice la sortie de
crise c'est la réponse à mes questions
je peux pas dire autrement bon
effectivement le parlement jusqu'à
présent a pas été terriblement associés
moi je suis rapporteur spécial au sein
de la commission des finances
tout un tas de questions je les ai posé
je n'ai pas eu de réponse donc les
réponses à mes questions oui c'est
l'impact financier
ça c'est quand même la moindre des
choses parce que aujourd'hui on connaît
l'impact du système actuel mais on ne
connaît pas l'impact de la réforme
proposée est quand même ce que je trouve
surprenant c'est que le haut commissaire
à la réforme des retraites dans le
rapport dit voilà voilà
jean paul delevoye un point ce sera 10
euros et on nous explique qu'il n'ya pas
de projection de fait mais alors comment
at on pu déterminer qu'un point c'était
très 10 euros c'est donc la première
chose c'est quand même d'avoir la
projection financière la fin des régimes
spéciaux très bien mais alors là c'est
un peu compliqué moi je souscris à
l'université l'universalité avec une un
régime de base avec le même rendement
pour tout le monde et c'est après oui il
faut tenir compte de la pénibilité c'est
évident mais la disparition des régimes
spéciaux moi j'ai pas la réponse à ces
questions
hier des avantages spécifiques sncf ratp
qu'on n'est pas en train d'accorder aux
autres régimes spéciaux ou aux autres
métiers qui serait pénible
or là j'ai quand même un certain nombre
de questions les enseignants qui n'ont
pas de primes et les fonctionnaires qui
ont 40 % de leur salaire en prime
comment on fait pour faire converger
c'est ces différents types d fonctionne
pas les sur le renseignement alors ça
c'est quand même un obstacle technique
le service des retraites de l'état ne
dispose des données concernant les
fonctionnaires que concernant les six
derniers mois
et là on va basculer leurs droits acquis
il va falloir reconstituer toute la
carrière mais le service de l'état des
retraits baradar n'a pas les données
concernant les fonctionnaires au delà
des 6 derniers mois et il va falloir
faire la transition
écoutez moi j'ai un certain nombre de
questions
et puis il ya aussi la gouvernance moi
je sais pas si c'est une étatisation
mais la réponse à la gouvernance il
faudra nous l'apporté aussi qui va
diriger ce système les partenaires
sociaux l'état
on a aussi cette grande question olivier
d'avoise vous entendez ici et bien
toutes les critiques des personnes qui
pourtant ne sont pas opposés au principe
d'une retraite par points vous en
revanche la cgtm réclame le retrait pur
et simple du projet de loi qu'est ce que
ce qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
aujourd'hui ouais bah ça m'inspire que
la cgt reste sur sa position de
d'exigence du retrait pur et simple
parce que même ceux qui portent cette
réforme avec plus ou moins de sincérité
ou de ou d'engagement politique on va
dire sont également très critique face à
la réforme telle qu'elle est présentée
est telle qu'elle s'articule telle
qu'elle évolue par face au rapport de
force
mis en place par des salariés en grève
donc c'est bien la preuve que le rapport
de force est nécessaire et utile
ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose
la grande question pour rejoindre
monsieur d'allier ces c'est bien la
question du financement
la cgt elle a des propositions qui sont
très claires mais qu'ils sont écoutés ni
par les parlementaires ni par l'exécutif
parce que il ya un combat idéologique là
qui est oui mais vous comprenez il faut
que les entreprises soient compétitives
et patati et patata
c'est mieux quand c'est oui la
compétition c'est bien mais les salariés
ce qu'il ya un truc qu'il faut surtout
pas oublier
on est dans un système qui est tel qu'il
est les salariés du pays s'inscrivent
dedans parce que c'est ce qui le travail
permet de vivre en espérant que ça se
fasse avec un minimum de dignité et dans
le respect des droits des salariés
maintenant la question c'est de savoir
c'est comment on finance la cotisation
sociale c'est la cotisation sociale qui
financent les retraites c'est donc le
travail je voulais évoquer tout à
l'heure puisqu'on parle de questions de
problèmes de financement bas déjà
revenant sur les exonérations de
cotisations sociales patronales
déjà pour tendance et nous commençons
déjà à remettre ça sur la table non moi
je suis pas d'accord avec ce que dit en
force dans la démocratie et des
élections et après il ya des
consultations avec les partenaires
sociaux et en établit des projets avec
les partenaires sociaux et est donc ce
que vous trouvez ça a été établi avec
une attention je vous dis c'est pas le
rapport de force qu'il faut c'est la
concertation
s'il n'y a pas de concertation des
maires dans la démocratie c'est ce
qu'ils veulent et doit donc je voudrais
mocratique je voudrais dire que il faut
mon comment est ce que on crée des
emplois parce que pour avoir des
cotisations faut créer des emplois et on
s'est rendu compte qu'on a
désindustrialisé parce qu'on avait des
entreprises des charges qui était trop
cher et avec le cic eu avec la baisse
des charges
on s'est rendu compte qu'on a créé deux
cent soixante mille emplois cette année
malgré peu de croissance et donc c'est
par ce biais qu'il faut aller il faut
qu' il faut clé parce que les pme les
pme il faut qu'elle soit compétitive
pour créer des emplois et donc je pense
que ce que vous avez dit il faut
continuer à diminuer les charges mais
aussi de la concertation avec les pics
d'odeur d'être en cause la garantie des
droits
au terme de ce débat mais juste un mot
sur le fait que le conflit quand même
semble s'enliser et que la grèce
poursuive et que malgré tout les pas que
pourra faire le gouvernement notamment
et bien la cgt où les partis ou les
personnes les personnes en grève
actuellement ne vont manifestement pas
terminée la grève est ce que le
gouvernement joue la carte du
pourrissement philippe dallier coûté le
calendrier c'est le gouvernement qui l'a
choisi à avoir lancé cette affaire au
début du mois de décembre on pouvait
facilement imaginer l'impact pour les
commerçants sur lesquels tout le monde
pleure et même le gouvernement
mais on pouvait effectivement deviner ce
qui allait se passer on aurait pu faire
ça à mon avis bien avant mais surtout
c'est le problème de la méthode globale
non c'est pas seulement le problème du
timing c'est qu'on voit bien que on nous
a dit il ya eu deux années de
concertation jean paul delevoye avec les
syndicats mais pour arriver dès le
départ
ah j'allais dire un rejet quasi complet
et et même de la part de la cfdt qui ne
veut pas entendre parler du recul de
l'âge de départ alors que le
gouvernement a bien compris qu'il ne
pourrait pas faire autrement que d'en
passer par là
donc cette situation de blocage je leur
ai pu être anticipé mais c'est d'abord
une question de méthode qui a péché la
méthode a pêché ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à cette discussion merci
sylvie vermeillet merci philippe dallier
merci olivier d'avoise et merci à daniel
chasse sans merci à tous autres sujets à
la une de l'actualité la tension qui
monte entre l'iran et les états unis
cette nuit téhéran a tiré des missiles
sur deux bases utilisées par l'armée
américaine en irak
une des postes qui intervient cinq jours
après l'assassinât du général soliman y
par les états unis explications de
sandra cerqueira
des frappes en séries c'est une base
militaire installée à 200 km au
nord-ouest de bagdad qui vient d'être
attaqué et ce sont les américains qui
sont visés dans ce communiqué le
pentagone précise qu'au total deux bases
irakiennes utilisé par l'armée
américaine ont été prises pour cible la
télévision iranienne annonce 80 victimes
au fil des mois les relations entre
téhéran et washington n'ont cessé de se
dégrader jusqu'à la frappe ciblée qui a
coûté la vie au général qasem soleimani
washington anticipaient cette riposte
iranienne
il y à une voie de sortie à la porte est
de téhéran
et c'est la désescalade ce qui
constituerait une nouvelle attitude pour
l'iran il se comporterait ainsi
davantage comme un pays normal c'est
raid revendiqué par téhéran marque un
tournant faisant redouter une escalade
régionales même si dirigeants américains
et iraniens ont rapidement semblé
vouloir calmer le jeu sur twitter le
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
évoque une réponse calibré affirmant que
le pays ne cherche ni l' escalade ni la
guerre des déclarations contradictoires
avec celles des gardiens de la
révolution l'armée iranienne menacée ce
matin de frapper israël et les alliés
des etats unis
donald trump a prévu de s'exprimer
aujourd'hui le guide suprême iranien a
quant à lui affirmé ce matin que les
tirs de missiles contre les américains
ne suffisent pas et on va parler de l'
escalade des tensions entre l'iran et
les états unis avec deux invités sur ce
plateau hélène conway mouret bonjour par
l'eau vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
représentant les français établis hors
de france vice présidente du sénat et
membre de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense
également sur ce plateau cédric perrin
bonjour vous êtes sénateur et l'air du
territoire de belfort vice président de
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de la défense jean hélène conway mouret
craignez vous que l'on aille vers une
guerre au moyen-orient après la réplique
cette nuit de l'iran son tir de missile
vers des bases américaines en irak
l'iran qui dit bien on le voit
d'ailleurs sur des tweets 1 qui ont été
données par l'iran qu'il s'agit de
représailles proportionnée telle est la
lecture que fait l'iran de ses frappes
cette nuit
d'abord je pense que les répliques
ou la réplique était prévisible oui
d'abord parce que on voit bien que ce
plan politique il y a eu un mouvement de
masse
une foule d'ailleurs où 50 personnes ont
trouvé la mort pour accompagner la
dépouille du général cela manille donc
je pense que le régime en place n'avait
pas le choix et du point de vue culturel
aussi il fallait et bien effacer
l'affront qui avait été fait à l'iran et
puisque ça quand on voit les mois qui a
été suscitée je pense qu'il faut
attendre aujourd'hui le discours de
donana femmes je pense que c'est dans ce
discours que l'on saura en effet ce que
les états unis souhaitent faire est ce
qu'ils veulent continuer si le président
trump qui n'est pas un va-t-en guerre et
qu'il a démontré jusqu'à présent et qui
aujourd'hui est entouré de monsieur
pompéo et de son gendre monsieur pompéo
qui on le sait comme monsieur bolton
avant lui veut absolument affaiblir
l'iran habilité terrible contre ce pays
le gendre de donald trump qui a dix ont
une amitié est en tout cas une relation
continue avec monsieur par israël
non pas simplement avec le prince
saoudien mohamed bensalah mme et on sait
très bien que aujourd'hui l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite sont dans une sorte de
conte test de leadership de la région
donc pour ces raisons-là donald trump
qui est entouré et très peu entouré
aujourd'hui puisqu'il a limogé
l'ensemble de ce qui était un peu
raisonnable autour de lui se retrouve
peut-être sous l'influencé de ce qui le
pousse à la guerre ou de ceux qui le
poussent pour d'autres raisons pour
favoriser l'arabie saoudite
eh bien on se retrouve avec un président
qui peut soit décider cet après-midi de
dire c'est fini et donc ils ramènent les
boys rom c'est ce qu'il avait annoncé
oui ou au contraire sous l'influencé de
son entourage est bien décidé de
continuer l'escaladent
guérir cédric perrin effectivement on
attend la prise de parole de donald
trump qui doit s'exprimer mercredi matin
à washington donc d'ici très peu de
temps et heure française
il s'est exprimé cependant donald trump
sur twitter en disant eh bien que pour
l'instant un sofa sogood at il dit
l'évaluation des dégâts et des victimes
est en cours jusqu'ici tout va bien nous
avons l'armé la plus puissante et la
mieux équipée au monde de loin et donc
il va faire une déclaration aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous cela vous inspire
qu'est-ce que ça m'inspire c'est surtout
que une fois de plus
on a l'impression que trump a agi en
dehors de toute stratégie et surtout
entourent de en dehors de toute
discussion multilatérale c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les organisations
internationales sont mises de côté comme
elles le sont depuis un certain temps
même dans maintenant dos nu
principalement et toutes les
organisations qui devrait être en tout
cas qui ont été créés après la deuxième
guerre mondiale pour tenter de régler ce
genre de propos de problèmes et éviter
justement les escalades l'escaladé à
laquelle hélène a fort justement bien
répondu à laquelle on est on est tous
par là par rapport à laquelle on est
tous inquiets donc voilà l'absence de
stratégie et un est un élément important
et puis l'action de des américains en
irak et c'est cet assassinat ciblé ci
fut dire va me permettre quand même
malheureusement aux iraniens et trouver
à nouveau un martyr et puis a tout les
atouts les groupuscules qui pourtant en
irak était anti iranien de se rassembler
derrière des rangs c'est ça qui est taxi
inquiétant parce que finalement
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
alors la france a dit annoncé que dans
le cadre de l'opération chat mâle et de
la coalition il n'allait pas se retirer
mais un certain nombre de pays ont
commencé à se retirer et on sait qu'ils
ont sous tous
on sait tous très bien que la lutte
contre des ch si on veut la continuer
elle ne pourra évidemment pas se faire
si la coalition sorte de l'irak est donc
la conséquence de tout cela c'est que la
finalité de toutes ces opérations
c'était quand même d'aller lutter contre
l'état islamiste liste l'état islamique
au moyen-orient et que non seulement la
fere kurde et maintenant la sphère
irakienne avec l'assassinât de soliman y
va entraîner en quelque sorte une
résurrection si j'allais dire de l'état
islamique et c'est ça qui m'inquiète
évidemment après il ya toute la
problématique de l' escalade et je pense
que personne n'a rien évidemment à
gagner à ce que la spirale de la
violence soit alimenté donc nous verrons
at il donné dans les heures qui viennent
ce qui se passera mais connaissant trump
et ayant quand même commencé à entendre
un petit peu c'est cesser ses propos
depuis quelques semaines je suis à 5
oui le général soliman y est plus
dangereux mort que vivant a estimé
d'ailleurs téhéran et on voit
effectivement que le premier effet c'est
que cela pourrait faire basculer
avec dans les bras de l'iran alors que
même qu'il y avait une grande
contestation de la place de la mainmise
de l'iran sur ce pays jusque là mais là
c'est un rassembler tout le monde contre
les états unis
et on voit bien que les états unis font
cavalier seul dans cette histoire ne
prennent aucun cas les intérêts des
européens
parce que si le moyen orient s'embrase
c'est quand même en europe que nous
aurons à nouveau agir et une crise
migratoire qui sont importantes
on a vu avec la syrie est aujourd'hui
avec ce qui s'est passé en syrie avec
les états unis finalement par la
décision prise tout seul aussi par
donald trump de force et dans les bras
de leurs ennemis les milices kurdes
aujourd'hui de se débarrasser des
milices iraniennes se sont quand même
les deux seules forces qui combattait
d'aef sur le terrain il ne faut pas
l'oublier donc sont hors jeu les deux
forces qui ont combattu d'aller sur le
terrain donc qui reste-t-il aujourd'hui
si en effet dash devait non pas revenir
pour créer un nouveau est un nouvel état
islamique comme ça a été le cas
auparavant
mais en tout cas avoir des actions
terroristes et les mener dans au
moyen-orient en afrique et un peu plus
loin donc je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans une situation où on analyse aussi
malheureusement la faiblesse de l'union
européenne où nous avons trois
dirigeants qui font un communiqué mais
quand même qui est de un verre d'eau
tiède enfin en disant voilà il faut une
désescalade
donc on voit que nous sommes sur la
touche que nous observant ce qui se
passe et que les seules puissances
aujourd'hui qui peuvent avoir un mot à
dire dans cette histoire c'est peut-être
la russie à nouveau dans quel camp sera
la russie et si demain les états unis
déclarent la guerre à l'iran dans quel
camp serons-nous vous parlez de tien
d'experts cela s'applique aux propos
qu'a eue emmanuel macron en début de
semaine avec un communiqué de
l'elysée dans lequel emmanuel macron a
souligné je le cite la profonde
préoccupation de la france face aux
événements restant en irak et dans la
région ainsi que sa détermination à
travailler à l'apaisement des tensions
et appelé l'iran à s'abstenir de toute
mesure de nature à aggraver l'escaladent
en cours
ce sont là les mots c'était avant les
frappes d'hier qu'est ce que vous pensez
vous de la position de la france dans
cette située à écouter je crois que
aujourd'hui tout le monde condamne cette
ses frappes évidemment je vois pas
comment on pourrait faire autrement on
voit bien que les les appels du
président à l'iran de ne pas répliquer
n'a pas forcément été très attendu
puisque s'est tenue salle non plus le
problème il est quand même
évidemment la france l'europe n'est pas
forcément viser par l'iran en matière de
deux frappes de rétorsion le problème
c'est qu'on sera un peu des victimes
collatérales de cette affaire là parce
que je rappelle quand même que 85% des
moyens qui sont employées moyen-orient
pour lutter contre d'âge sont des moyens
américains là mais l'europe aujourd'hui
montrent effectivement une fois de plus
sa faiblesse son inexistence les presque
dire et le problème c'est que les
européens n'ont évidemment pas les
moyens
s'affranchir de l'aide américaine dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme donc
aujourd'hui on a une position position
particulièrement délicate où barkan se
fait avec évidemment une aide américaine
et et nous n'allons pas non plus nous
nous mettre à dos entre guillemets de
nos alliés américains sans quoi barkan
qui est déjà largement discuté parce que
certaines des personnes s'interrogent
sur la suite de barkan légitimement sans
les américains ce n'est plus possible
donc on est on est on est on est on est
confronté aujourd'hui à un ordre mondial
qui fait que l'europe n'existe pas et
c'est une c'est une leçon nouvelle que
nous impose cette crise c'est là que
alors que nous sommes à une demi heure
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et qu'elle va refiler est
en train d'arriver
salah des conférences un quart d'heure
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
hélène conway mouret autre crainte
possible c'est celle et bien du de
l'accord de vienne sur le nucléaire
iranien s'est déjà un accord on peut le
dire qu'ils étaient moribonds depuis
qu'il avait été dénoncée par washington
mais là il est ce qu'il est
définitivement avec son son coup de
grâce et donc du coup est ce que faire
partie sur bien l'enrichissement de
l'uranium pour l'iran pour vous et
toutes les craintes sur la bombe
nucléaire mais le premier le problème
c'est que aujourd'hui les iraniens ne
sont plus tenus par cet accord puisqu'il
a été dénoncé par les états unis et que
donc finalement ils sont à nouveau
libres alors fils aubin ils ont dit
dimanche se sont dits oui
s'affranchissent des avions mais de
l'accord sur l'enrichissement de noël
heures de l'uranium est perçu et donc
les européens au récit de les contenir
jusqu'à présent mais on voit bien et je
crois que nous venons de dire tous les
deux la même chose que nous avons
aujourd'hui malheureusement la faiblesse
de l'europe dans toute sa splendeur qui
était allé au grand jour et moi ce que
je crains c'est que on voyait depuis des
semaines voire des mois une contestation
sociale très importante en iran bon
aujourd'hui l'assassinât du général
sony a fait en sorte que et bien les
iraniens se sont retrouvés à soutenir un
régime honni
donc il allait peut-être se débarrasser
en interne avec un changement de régime
qui était programmé puisqu'il y aura des
élections au printemps prochain et que
finalement aujourd'hui ces populations
se retrouvent derrière ce dont il
voulait se débarrasser mais qui sont là
finalement pour les protéger parce que
l'iran est à nouveau fermé sur lui même
tout ce qui avait été proposé est
annoncé en tout cas par les réformateurs
et bien ne se passe pas puisque
aujourd'hui les entreprises étrangères
sont partis les investissements qui
devait arriver en masse en iran n'ont
pas eu lieu et donc ce pays qui était
étouffer économiquement et bien va je
pense malheureusement remettre au
pouvoir
les mollahs et tous ceux dont les
iraniens ne voulaient plus et donc on va
avoir un durcissement avec à nouveau les
conservateurs au pouvoir je pense et on
en parlera dans quelques semaines je
crois ou dans quelques mois quand auront
lieu les élections locales
cédric perrin est ce que l'on peut
trouver une issue pour vous à cette
crise et qu'elle peut elle être coûté
une issue
il faut aussi enfin il faut aussi se
mettre dans le contexte américain je ne
défends pas évidemment de donald trump
dont je je condamne évidemment le
l'action souvent irréfléchies souvent
beaucoup trop douté mais faut se mettre
aussi en place des américains qu'ils se
font attaquer de toutes parts depuis un
certain temps et qui ont réagi le
problème le problème le problème des
attaques c'est quand même que c'est
juste que je disais en commençant cette
émission c'est qu'ils s'affranchissent
de toute réglementation internationale
ils sont du bilatéralisme là on devrait
être dans du multilatéralisme
donc c'est ça la vraie question c'est
est-ce que à un moment donné ou à un
autre ils vont revenir autour de la
table et accepter que l'un certaines
décisions puissent être prises au sein
des organisations qui sont prévus pour
cela ou non c'est une des questions
importantes qui doit pouvoir permettre
de sortir de tout ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous renvoie bien que
vous parliez tout à l'heure de l'accord
sur le nucléaire les iraniens ont beau
jeu de dire l'accord nucléaire n'est pas
mort à la condition coeur on accepte de
lever toutes les sanctions économiques
contre 12 facile de dire ça n'arrivera
jamais et les russes disent mais il
accordait pas morts on va continuer
c'est travailler pour mais on sent bien
que cet assassinat ciblé
à comme le disait très bien et hélène à
ressouder un certain nombre de gens qui
s'étaient divisés
donc aujourd'hui la question c'est de
savoir jusqu'où jusqu'à quelle barreaux
de l'échelle on va monter on va faire
monter le comment le lec engage la
spirale de la violence se verront
refuser quand même d'accorder un visa au
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
pour qu'il se déplace au conseil de
sécurité c'est bien vous méprisent la
merci à un moment c'est autour d'une
table et c'est pas simplement de la
gesticulation diplomatique à laquelle
nous prêtons sans grand succès mais
c'est au tour du conseil de la table du
conseil de sécurité que ces choses là
doivent être discutés donc on a aussi la
une
une façon américaine de traiter les
choses peut-être que faudrait-il que ce
conseil de sécurité se réuniront à
genève et on va avoir un début de
réponse affectivement avec on a déjà la
réponse que l'on attende de donald trump
cet après-midi merci à tous j'assiste
quand même sur le fait que ça n'a pas
commencé sous donald trump et que sous
d'obama en 2000 tous à commencer en 2013
sous d'obama donc nous disons que trump
et il le fasse avec violence s'est passé
une politique américaine ne s'est pas
une petite trump heist d'accord merci
beaucoup accusaient d'avoir participé à
ce que vos questions également dans
l'actualité du jour la conférence de
presse de carlos ghosn après sa fuite la
semaine dernière du japon l'ex patron de
renault nissan s'explique aujourd'hui de
pied à beyrouth
on va l'écouter et puis tout de suite
après une réaction avec alexandre
poussin salle des conférences
j'ai fui l'injustice la persécution ont
suivi plus de 400 jours dans un système
inhumain conçu pour meuron
je n'avais pas d'autre choix que de me
protéger ainsi que ma famille ça a été
une décision difficile et un risque
qu'on ne prend si on est résigné à la
possibilité d'un procès inéquitable et
on va tout de suite rejoindre je le
disais alexandre poussa qui est salle
des conférences un de cette salle qui
jouxte l'hémicycle vont débuter des
questions d'actualité d'ici un quart des
environs vous êtes avec sophie primas la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat pour une réaction
oui sophie primas carlos ghosn estime
que la justice japonaise a voulu le
risée est ce que vous le croyez écoutez
moi je n'ai pas à le croire ou ne pas le
croire je vois depuis trois quarts
d'heure cette conférence de presse où je
trouve un carlos ghosn d'abord
extrêmement combatif quelque peu fébrile
on voit si vous me permettez
l'expression qu'il en a gros sur la
patate et qu'il a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à dire quitte parfois d'ailleurs
un peu se disperser et avoir du mal à
arrêter le flot d'informations qui nous
donne mais néanmoins il a effectivement
une attaque très très forte à la fois de
l'entreprise nissan des dirigeants de
certains dirigeants d'entreprise nissan
parce qu'on sent que sa relation avec
l'entreprise nissan c'est autre chose
mais que certains dirigeants de
l'entreprise essonne et après le parquet
en particulier japonais où il dénonce
une collusion entre le parquet et
l'entreprise les dirigeants l'entreprise
insan
et justement il parle lui d'un complot
industrielle du côté de nissan est ce
que ce complot industriels et les
probables ce complot industriel c'est sa
lecture des évènements qui le concerne
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui enfin il est
venu et beaucoup de documents ils
projettent d'après ce que je comprends
beaucoup de documents sur les murs là de
sa salle de conférences des décisions du
conseil d'administration des votes du
conseil d'administration il se justifie
sur sa place et se justifie sur
éventuellement des ressentiments très
important de dirigeants de nissan qui
considèrent comme étant non compétent
puisque ayant mis nissan dans une
situation économique difficile depuis
son propre départ à lui il met en avant
des
un peu d'hypocrisie de la part de
dirigeants de nissan des ressentis et
surtout un manque de confiance les
dirigeants nissan vis-à-vis de la france
et lorsque c'est ce que cette affaire
peut avoir des conséquences sur
l'alliance franco-japonaise entre
renault et nissan
écoutez je pense que de toute façon ça
va avoir des conséquences dans l'esprit
tout un chacun sur nissan
jean dominique senard qui dirige
aujourd'hui l'alliance va devoir faire
face à ces difficultés qui sont des
difficultés d'attac
ces importantes carlos ghosn n'est pas
homme à se laisser enterrer donc je
pense que ces attaques vont continuer sa
défense va continuer donc il va falloir
que l'alliance nissan soit extrêmement
clair également sur les accusations
qu'elle porte à l'encontre de carlos
ghosn donc oui je pense que les
turbulences dans la gouvernance vont
être importantes et moi je suis très
inquiète évidemment pour notre groupe
renault en france
alors merci beaucoup sophie primas pour
votre réaction merci alexandre pour
cette nouvelle réaction et j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir sur son plateau
emilie zapolsky bonjour vous êtes
communiquant de fondatrice de l'agencé
emilie conseille d'abord et bien votre
regard de communicante sur cette
opération de communication bien préparé
de carlos ghosn sur cette conférence de
presse où effectivement et bien l'ex
patron de renault nissan a parlé de
complot industriels à son encontre m
fanta sont intactes mais aujourd'hui il
y avait un enjeu véritablement de
communication d'image et même
d'information parce que il traîne quand
même cette image de fugitifs qui a
travaillé avec on pourrait dire des
malfrats pour organiser sa fuite du
japon jusqu'au liban
donc il ya cette image là très forte il
doit contrebalancer avec une image son
image d'entrepreneurs de ne pas signer
de grands patrons qui a sauvé nissan de
la faillite qui a mené renault nissan
depuis des années dans des belles
perspectives et
ces attaques le côté victimes du parquet
japonais des pratiques de la justice
japonaise qui l'a enfermé dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas acceptables
donc il doit contrebalancer ça il le
sait très bien c'est pour ça qu'il ya
cette offensive assez forte à la fois
vis-à-vis du parquet japonais vis-à-vis
aussi des dirigeants de l'entreprise qui
auraient comploté ou qui aurait
manigancé contre lui donc il ya il prend
l'offensive quoi ils commencent à
attaquer plutôt qu'à être attaquée pour
porter cette image de victimes
d'entrepreneurs qui a fait du business
et qui a eu reçu donc les échos d'un
business réalisé
plutôt que de faire perdurer cette image
de fugitifs qui peuvent faire rigoler
par moments on parle même d'une série
netflix en préparation ou en négociation
mais qui est pas drôle du tout parce que
c'est quand même une personnalité riche
dans le haut de gamme des entrepreneurs
qui peut fuir qu'il travaille donc avec
des malfrats il ya quand même cette
gravité de situations et même au sein du
liban parce qu'on est quand même dans un
pays chrétien nivea matic même il ya une
révolte sociale et une révolte de la
population justement contre la
corruption du gouvernement des
dirigeants donc voilà il fallait
travailler avec ça alors il est très
bien conseillé en matière de
communication et il a pris les devants
ça va pas se terminer
c'est un une personnalité combative qui
va pas s'arrêter là qui va se défendre
et ça sera à mon avis un long un long
long long procès qui va durer très très
longtemps
cela alors que l'on venait de voir
arriver la ministre elisabeth bourdin
dans la salle des conférences on est à
quelques minutes des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et le sujet
à la une de l'actualité de 2020 qui
était déjà en 2019 c'est la réforme des
retraites comment est-ce que vous jugez
et bien la gestion de cette crise par
l'exécutif cette crise qui perdure cette
crise jamais vue et qui dépasse déjà le
mouvement de 95 ans mais écoutez moi je
me suis posé la question à l'heure
actuelle qu'est-ce que joue le
gouvernement puisqu'il ya eu plusieurs
lauriad eu beaucoup de flou sur cette
réforme dont on ne connaît toujours pas
véritablement le contenu on ne connaît
pas aussi le coût des concessions qui
ont été faites à différentes professions
comme les policiers les militaires les
marins pêcheurs et danseurs de l'opéra
de paris jean l'oubli encore il y en a
je pense une dizaine on n'a pas non plus
les répercussions que cette réforme va
avoir sur chacun d'entre nous puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de simulation
on n'a pas une idée par exemple de
combien s'appliquent pas au cas
particulier c'est impossible pour
l'instant de savoir oui mais même de
direction par exemple on peut imaginer
que comme cette réforme porte sur toutes
les années de salaire plutôt que sur 25
ans ou six mois pour les fonctionnaires
ça a eu une baisse mécanique
mathématiques on n'a pas d'argument du
gouvernement il ya énormément de flou et
puis là où je me pose la question c'est
qu'est-ce que joue le gouvernement s qui
joue ce qui pèse les bénéfices et les
risques de garder notamment l'âge pivot
les bénéfices étant de faire plaisir à
son électorat de droite à départ pour
pour les élections futures
ça suffira pas à l'âge pivot peut-être
en voie d oui mais on voit bien que les
attaques des républicains ces six
appalaches pivot c'est pas une réforme
du tout donc on voit que ça sonne ça
sonne juste un l'âge pivot où
l'équilibré financier pour les électeurs
de droite
est-ce qu'il veut jouer ce bénéfice là
haut risque comme des avantages de
garder ce malaise social
la rue qui gronde moi j'ai l'impression
qu'il est en train de fonctionner comme
ça en noyant un petit peu le poisson
avec ce projet de loi dont on ne connaît
pas encore le détail qui va venir très
rapidement conseil des ministres qui va
venir très rapidement au parlement avec
une procédure accélérée
on voit qu'ils jouent la montre pour
passer à autre chose et essayer de
calmer le jeu
c'est là alors que l'on voit notamment
arrivées christophe castaner derrière
lui laurent piètre à skis le nouveau
secrétaire mais sur votre retraite le
nouveau monsieur retraites qui
d'ailleurs est bien a eu un premier aura
compliqué où hier ici au sénat également
à l'assemblée nationale difficile pour
le nouveau secrétaire d'état aux
retraites d'intervenir dans ce contexte
de connaître correctement ces dossiers
alors même qu'on est dans ce moment de
contestation alors je pense qu'il
connaissait auparavant le dossier mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas la même
personnalité que jean paul delevoye qui
avait installé en plus avec les
syndicats un rapport de enfin une
relation de négociations qui étaient
assez apprécié donc là il est nouveau y
débarque et à un moment où tout le monde
attend donc c'est attendre des
précisions à la toujours avec cette
vision très précis donc il ya une
pression très forte de tous les côtés
toute l'opposition et
vent debout contre cette réforme la rue
les syndicats sont vent debout il y en a
pas un qui fait alliance avec le
gouvernement puisque fameux pivot qui
bloque les syndicats réformistes
donc il ya cette espèce de goulots
d'étranglement sur cette semaine de
nouvelles concertations
moi j'ai l'impression que le projet il
va passer mais avec comme un comme une
coquille vide c'est-à-dire qui ne sera
pas à la hauteur de ce qu avait projeté
au départ le gouvernement à ce qu'est un
début de lumière au bout du tunnel quand
on voit que le gouvernement saisit la
balle au bond sur la conférence de
financement de la cfdt ont semblé
dubitatif sa part je trouve que c'est un
petit peu l'argument de dire ya un
problème on crée un comité pour moi
c'est un petit peu noyé le poisson alors
c'est un pas en avant parce que qui dit
conférence de financement dit équilibre
financier
donc peut-être un autre moyen que l'âge
pivot oulhaj déquilibre mais j'ai
l'impression que ça intervient tellement
part que c'est difficile pour les
syndicats dit croire réellement et ça va
encore durer puisque andy conférence de
financement qui pourrait durer jusqu'en
juillet on voit bien qu'il ya une espèce
de décalage en même temps d'accélération
du projet de loi et d'état l'âge des
problèmes pour les diluer pour pour que
ce ne soit plus source de conflits et de
et de rues de manifestations de rue on
voit bien que le gouvernement cherche là
un moyen de s'en sortir et le
gouvernement bien coincé entre cas selon
vous à emilie d'appel ski merci beaucoup
pour tout ces éclairages en vous
retrouver un juste après les questions
d'actualité qui commence dans trois
minutes maintenant et tout de suite on
va rejoindre alexandre poussard salle à
des conférences vous êtes avec jean yves
le conte car elle ya un autre sujet qui
va largement occupé cette séance de
questions d'actualité bien c'est l'iran
et les relations avec les états unis
oui jean yves le conte tout d'abord une
première réaction à cette attaque
iranienne sur des bases américaines en
irak et 7000 attaques non mortels est ce
que c'est une réponse proportionnée de
l'iran vous êtes tout il ya en matière
de violence en justice jamais une
violence par une autre violence
chaque acte doit être jugé en soi donc à
partir du moment où l'iran décidé de
viser des cibles en irak de cette
manière là y'a rien qui peut être
justifiée même pas l'assassinât d'un de
ses généraux on ne peut pas justifier
dans la sagesse c'est certainement pas
de rentrer d'accepter l'invitation à
rentrer dans une escalade de la violence
d'accord alors ce cette montée des
violences entre les etats-unis et l'iran
elle pose la question de la coalition
internationale en irak
cette coalition elle est en danger c'est
à dire que c'est effectivement très très
inquiétant parce que la réaction
irakienne à l'action des états unis
montrent que l irak eux ne souhaitent
plus le parlement irakien a clairement
dit qu'il ne souhaitait plus la présence
de la coalition internationale en irak
alors que la la la la guerre contre
l'état islamique n'est pas de terminer
donc s'il a plus de coalition
internationale qui va faire la guerre
contre l'état islamique et et la
question était posée la question l'irak
doit faire preuve aussi de
responsabilités en la matière mais on
comprend bien que comme nous tous nous
avons été choqués par cette cette
décision américaine de la semaine
dernière et les les conséquences qu'elle
a donc le parlement irakien
on peut comprendre sa réaction mais
maintenant la question c'est nous avons
besoin d'eux que la coalition
internationale puisse continuer à lutter
contre les tests et ce n'est pas terminé
et alors qu'ils y dans sur le terrain
dans les têtes et alors qu'est ce que
peut faire la france l'europe face à
cette montée des tensions
note ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est
essentiel c'est justement de ne jamais
justifié justement jamais de dire qu'une
réponse est proportionnée ce n'est pas
le cas aucune on ne peut pas justifier
une turpitude par une autre turpitudes
chaque violation du droit international
est une violation du droit international
et l'une lui n'engendre pas le droit à
une autre donc ce que doit faire ce que
peut faire la france déjà cessé de
s'inscrire en militante du respect du
droit international pour faire en sorte
que et de ne pas ne pas accepter d'être
conduite à être solidaire des etats-unis
pour des actes que nous ne partageons
pas très bien merci beaucoup j'arrive le
compte pour votre réponse on va tout de
suite allé dans l'hémicycle du sénat car
les questions d'actualité vont commencer
et quand un câble mais quel est le
programme aujourd'hui et bien alexandre
aujourd'hui au programme de ces quinze
questions d'actualité trois sujets
notamment qui vont beaucoup revenir vous
en parliez est la crise entre l'iran et
les états unis bien sûr il va y avoir
trois questions sur ce sujet aujourd'hui
mais tout d'abord on va commencer dans
quelques instants avec deux questions
sur la réforme des retraites au
lendemain on l'a vu au sénat de ce débat
en présence de lui remplir de laurent
pied trajet ce qui le nouveau secrétaire
d'état à la réforme des retraites et on
avait vu hier un les sénateurs très
sévère avec la prestation de ce
secrétaire d'état on va voir aujourd'hui
la teneur de ces questions donc on va
deux questions dès le début de cette
séance d'actualité consacrée à la
réforme des retraites
autre sujet l'escaladé tension donc avec
les états unis et l'iran au moins deux
questions venues des communistes et des
centristes sur ce sujet après les
frappes cette nuit de l'iran contre des
bases abritant des soldats américains en
irak la france a condamné ces frappes
qu'elle a qualifié d' attaque c'est jean
yves le drian qui l'a fait savoir
aujourd'hui dans un communiqué la france
appelle aujourd'hui à la désescalade
d'ailleurs les questions sont adressées
à jean yves le drian on verra s'il
répondra dans quelques instants
troisième sujet qui va faire la une
aujourd'hui cette décision de la cour
d'appel de paris de déclarer qu billy
traoré
le meurtrier de sarah halimi pénalement
irresponsable on va voir la mobilisation
de deux groupes parlementaires pour
poser des questions à ce sujet à la
garde des sceaux dans quelques instants
puisque le président est en train de
s'installer dans l'hémicycle qui se
trouvait derrière moi et donc on va voir
toutes ces questions aujourd'hui
retraite escalade des tensions entre les
etats-unis et l'iran et enfin la faire à
ça allait me c'est parti pour cette
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
[Musique]
pas reçu d'observation je n'envoie pas
un séance est donc adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé
ja forme le sénat que la commission
mixte paritaire sheila chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
relatif à la lutte contre le gaspillage
et à l'économie circulaire est parvenu à
l'adoption d'un texte commun
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun sera attentif au respect du sein
et des hautes haies aux temps de parole
la première question est ta madame
monique lubin notre collègue pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous avons eu hier dans cet
hémicycle un débat sur la réforme des
retraites qui fut je dois le dire fort
édifiant entre les atermoiements les
incohérences et les imprécisions
nous avons finalement été confortés sur
un point la cacophonie à laquelle nous
assistons depuis plusieurs mois sur ce
sujet arrive à son apogée
je résume en substance l'âge pivot aucun
problème puisque ne seront concernés que
quelques cas d'espèce tous les autres
entendent plus tardivement dans la vie
active
les milliers de cas d'espèce
apprécieront le coût financier des
différentes transitions
nous restons enveloppe constante
débrouillez vous avec ça la mise en
place d'outils de simulation pour les
carrières déjà effectués c'est très
compliqué donc effectivement comme l'adn
de nos collègues nous ne sommes pas
prêts d'avoir des outils de simulation
pour les carrières à venir les
conditions de réversion pour les
conjoints survivants les plus souvent
des conjointes à 64 ans au lieu de 55
plus rien pour les femmes divorcées avec
les conséquences induites pour les
femmes victimes de violences
réponse nous attendons un rapport de
l'igas comme s'il fallait être un
rapport de l'igas pour imaginer les
conséquences de telles mesures
et l'on peut rajouter à cela toutes les
garanties déjà apporté à quelques
professions de maintien de leurs
systèmes propres ce qui veut bien dire
que l'universalité telle que vous la
concevez sera impossible et que si vous
allez au bout vous créerez des
inégalités majeur parce que seules
certaines catégories de salariés se
verront infliger une réforme au rabais
monsieur le ministre ce qui se conçoit
bien s'énonce clairement et les mots
pour le dire arrivent aisément
j'en conclus donc que vous êtes très
loin de concevoir clairement ce que vous
voulez faire quand prendrez-vous la
seule décision qui s'impose retirer ce
projet non abouti
et clairement anxiogène pouvons répondre
la parole et aux secrétaires d'état
servair fait monsieur laurent pital de
ce qu'ils n'avaient la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice monique lubin
oui c'est vrai hier nous avons eu une
première série des changes sur le projet
que nous avons de transformer notre
système de retraites et sur le fond vous
avez souhaité souligner un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes ou de questions que
vous avez vous les avez reprises ici
dans une question relativement large
d'abord vous dire que l'âge déquilibre
n'est que sur le fond la résultante d'un
dispositif qui a des cotisations et des
pensions et qui effectivement dans un
système par répartition les cotisations
servent à payer les pensions
il est donc cohérent qu'à un moment
donné le système soit l équilibre retour
d'un âge ce n'est pas tabou que de dire
cela
d'ailleurs cette référence collective la
notion de durée elle a d'ailleurs été
régulièrement utilisé par les uns ou par
les autres
et si j'ai bonne mémoire au travers de
réforme de 2014 sur l'idée de ramener
tout le monde au 2 bis cas en deux les
35 à 43 ans ce qui est aussi une autre
forme de
une référence collectif sur lequel il
faut s'appuyer sur les outils de
simulation il y a aujourd'hui à
disposition pour tous les français qui
le souhaitent des simulations sur le
site retraite point gouv
il y a des cas d'espèce la question qui
a été posée c'est à partir de quand
pourrons-nous avoir des simulations à
titre individuel lié au parcours de
chacun j'ai répondu hier je réponds vos
corps aujourd'hui lorsque les paramètres
seront au final complètement déterminé
et que la loi aura été votée nous serons
bien sûr en mesure de faire des
simulations qui seront complètement
incohérent pour l'ensemble des français
voilà bah bah écoutez monsieur le
ministre je crois que je crois que tout
est dit quand les paramètres quand nous
aurons voté quand nous serons en
capacité de déterminer les paramètres
vous pourrez savoir à quelle sauce vous
serez manger franchement ce n'est pas
sérieux votre projet je le répète n'est
pas abouti et nous ne pouvons pas livré
les français en pâture comme cela sur un
projet aussi peu aboutis la parole est
maintenant président claude malhuret
pour me coupe les indépendants
république et territoires
monsieur le premier ministre ma formule
dans le débat d'hier sur la france en
marche arrière et les français en marche
à pied visait bien sûr ceux qui depuis
plus d'un mois paralyse le pays
chaque jour qui passe démontre à quel
point ceux qui prétendent défendre les
français et le service public se moque
des obligations et de la réputation du
service public et de la détresse des
français surtout les plus fragiles
au moment où dans le calme nos voisins
européens ont tiré les conséquences de
l'allongement de la vie en reculant
l'âge de la retraite en france les
démagogues d'extrême droite et d'extrême
gauche propose la retraite à 60 ans pour
eux l'argent public c'est tout les
chakras ouvert tout le monde peut se
servir mais les français savent que la
réforme est inéluctable déséquilibre
démographique déficit structurel coûts
des régimes spéciaux sont une épée de
damoclès sur nos retraites dans un pays
où le système coûte 14 % du pib contre
10 % en moyenne en europe
au fur et à mesure des discussions on
voit bien que l'on je porte sur un sujet
principal celui de l' équilibre donc de
la pérennité du système français de
retraite vous avez raison monsieur le
premier ministre de refuser d'entrer
dans la distinction purement rhétorique
entre réforme systémique et réforme
paramétrique
la réalité est bien plus simple le
système de têtes et qui livrés sur le
long terme et il doit être sur le court
terme c'est tous âges pivots
augmentation de l'âge de départ ou
conférences de financement nous
concevons tout ce qu'on puisse discuter
des modalités mais penser que la réforme
va s'équilibrer tout seul surtout avec
l'augmentation de la facture à chaque
rendez vous avec les partenaires sociaux
c'est comme prétendent qu'on va gagner
un marathon avec des chaussures de ski
vendredi prochain sera nous dit on le
jour de l'épreuve de vérité
êtes vous déterminez monsieur le premier
ministre a abordé ce rendez-vous en
tenant le nécessaire langage de vérité
sur l' équilibre financier de nos
retraites
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
l'apparent le cas monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président malgré une
permuter bon avant de répondre à la
question que vous venez de poser de
saluer et de souhaiter à tous les
membres du sénat une excellente année
2020 monsieur le président malgré je
serais tenté de répondre à la question
que vous posez par une réponse courte
simple et net oui mais vous me diriez à
juste titre que ce serait un peu court
jeune homme et donc je voudrais en dire
un peu plus oui la question de l'
équilibre de nos systèmes de retraites
est une question légitime est une
exigence que nous devons poser
oui bien entendu car notre système
actuel avec ses 42 régime est un système
fondé et c'est heureux sur la
répartition c'est-à-dire sur la
solidarité entre les générations des
actifs payent pour les retraités
et sur la solidarité entre les
professions plus exactement à
l'intérieur d'un régime et parfois avec
d'autres régimes nous le savons au coeur
du système de retraite il ya lyon cette
notion de solidarité
notre système est d'ailleurs un système
qui a permis à la france d'avoir le plus
faible taux de pauvreté parmi les
retraités partout en europe et c'est une
excellente chose et c'est évidemment
monsieur le président ma durée
ce que nous voulons préserver tous
ensemble dans cet hémicycle et en france
je le crois tous ensemble mais la
solidarité ça n'est pas c'est même le
contraire de l'irresponsabilité on peut
parfaitement accepté l'idée que les
actifs payent pour les retraités mais il
y aurait quelque chose d' irresponsable
et de finalement très peu solidaires à
dire que on arrivant pas à financer les
pensions alors les actifs laisserait à
leurs enfants le soin de payer leur
pension plus la dette autrement dit je
le dis l'équilibré d'un système est en
soi un objectif est également un
objectif de solidarité et de
responsabilité
je les dis depuis le début et je
continuerai à le dire jusqu'au bout ce
qui est vrai monsieur le président
malhuret
c'est que dans tous les autres pays
d'europe et dans tous les autres pays
comparables à la france c'est à dire
attachés à la solidarité c'est-à-dire
attachés à l'état de droit c'est à dire
au fond des grandes démocraties
occidentales auxquelles nous pouvons
nous comparer les décisions ont été
prises partout de retarder l'âge de
départ à la retraite
c'est vrai en belgique c'est vrai en
allemagne c'est vrai au royaume uni
c'est vrai en italie c'est vrai partout
pourquoi parce que le ratio entre les
actifs et les retraités se modifie parce
que l'espérance de vie augmente et parce
qu'il faut bien justement faire en sorte
que les actifs puissent payer pour les
pensionnés sens
bear ou sans se trouver dans une
situation trop délicat et c'est très
bien et la réponse qui a été trouvé par
tout ça a été de travailler
progressivement un peu plus longtemps
dans tous les états lorsque l'on touche
au système de retraite quel que soit le
système dans lequel il est organisé ça
crée forcément de l'émotion mais tous
les pays ont réussi à le faire
alors qu'en france depuis très longtemps
depuis depuis que je m'intéresse aux
questions publiques
à chaque fois qu'on évoque la question
des retraites on suscite une émotion une
inquiétude une mobilisation souvent
considérables et chacun ici a des
souvenirs sur les éléments de réforme
qui ont été apportées au système et qui
ont suscité des mobilisations et des
oppositions
j'observe d'ailleurs que bien souvent
ceux qui aujourd'hui critique le projet
critiqué les évolutions des systèmes
antérieurs qui le défendent aujourd'hui
c'est comme ça c'est parfois des choses
curieuses mais ça arrive notre objectif
monsieur le président ma durée c'est de
créer un système universel universel
équitable et responsable
un système universel c'est à dire que
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français quelle que soit leur profession
leur métier auront les mêmes droits et
seront soumis aux mêmes contraintes et
cet essai est un élément de justice et
d'efficacité
c'est même un élément d'adaptation au
monde tel qu'il se transforme
car de plus en plus les carrières
professionnelles sont variées et
diverses telles personnes qui un jour
est fonctionnaire devient salarié puis
ensuite indépendant nous savons que les
carrières professionnelles sont hachées
nous savons qu'elles sont diverses et
nous savons qu'un système universel par
points et par répartition permettra de
bien mieux prendre en compte la
diversité des parcours professionnels la
fluidité des parcours professionnels et
la justice entre nos concitoyens à
laquelle évidemment nous sommes tous
attachés
le projet de loi sera présenté
prochainement conseil des ministes il
sera présenté et c'est bien naturel à
l'assemblée nationale à la fin du mois
de février le sénat
on connaîtra à partir du mois d'avril la
discussion j'en suis certain sera dense
sera riche et sera passionné je
l'attends avec impatience
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
roger karoutchi pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le premier ministre la
république se doit d'être protectrice de
tous les citoyens
sarah halimi a été massacrée défenestré
par un meurtrier clairement antisémite
il n'y aura pas de procès
au delà des règles au delà des codes
monsieur le premier ministre est ce que
vous trouvez cela juste pour vont
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs des sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur il ya un peu plus
de deux ans madame ali bin de nos
concitoyennes étaient assassinés de
façon atroce nous en conservons tous la
mémoire une décision de justice récente
que vous évoquez a ravivé le souvenir de
ce drame et susciter dans la société
française et au sein de ce parlement
peut-être un très grand nombre
d'interrogations par une décision du 19
décembre la cour d'appel de paris a
déclaré l'auteur des faits irresponsable
pénalement en raison et je cite la
décision monsieur le sénateur en raison
d'un trouble psychique ayant aboli son
discernement au moment du crime c'est le
texte de la décision
la cour a toutefois reconnu aussi
l'existence de charges suffisantes à son
égard d'avoir commis ce meurtre
elle a reconnu l'existence d'une
circonstance aggravante liés à la
motivation antisémite de l'acte c'est
également dans la décision
je me contente de citer le texte de la
cour elle a enfin décidé c'est elle qui
le dit de mesures coercitives contre le
meurtrier en l'occurrence une
hospitalisation sans consentement
voilà ce que nous dit la justice
vous savez parfaitement en me posant
cette question vous me demandez si je
trouve cette décision juste vous savez
parfaitement me posant cette question
qu'en tant que chef du gouvernement
il ne m'appartient pas de porter une
appréciation sur une décision de justice
et vous savez parfaitement pour avoir
exercé des responsabilités
gouvernementales
pourquoi ce principe est un principe
essentiel est important l'émotion
suscitée par la décision a été vive les
questions que pose cette décision sont
des questions sérieuses
la cour a utilisé une procédure
une façon de juger dirais-je qui a été
créée en 2008 et qui permet de juger et
c'est important de l'avoir en tête en
audience publique
les faits commis par un individu dont
l'irresponsabilité pénale a été reconnue
c'est en vérité déjà une façon d'essayer
d'essayer de mieux prendre en compte la
question que vous évoquez pas sur ces
faits mais la question générale que vous
évoquez peut-être cette décision suscite
ratel au-delà de l'émotion
un débat et si débat il doit y avoir un
gouvernement
il prendra sa part mais je veux dire
d'une part qu'il est normal important et
légitime que le gouvernement ne se
prononcent pas et ne donne pas une
appréciation sur les décisions justice
sans quoi séparation des pouvoirs grands
principes républicains
tout cela partirait à vau l'eau tout
cela partir un voleur et je veux dire
également
je veux dire également que le fait que
la cour est par sa décision reconnu la
circonstance aggravante et le caractère
antisémite de l'acte est un élément
qu'il faut'' en permanence rappelé à
ceux
qui dans un premier temps ou de façon
systématique on indiqué on laissait
penser que l'acte en question aurait pu
ne pas être motivé par ces circonstances
voilà ce que je veux dire monsieur le
sénateur à la question que vous posez
quant à savoir si je trouve juste ou non
cette décision
je garderai la réponse pour moi monsieur
karoutchi
monsieur le premier ministre
merci pour cette réponse loin de moi
l'idée de remettre en cause ou la
neutralité du gouvernement où
l'indépendance des magistrats
mais enfin monsieur le premier ministre
dans un pays où aujourd'hui quand on
marche dans un parc à villejuif quand on
marche dans une rue à metz quand on
marche dans une gare à paris on peut
croiser à tout moment qu'un qui dispose
d'un couteau et qui peut à tout moment
nous dire puisque c'est maintenant au
rythme des déséquilibres et qu'à ce
moment là il n'avait pas toute sa
conscience
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce que ça
veut dire que ces gens là sont
irresponsables pénalement pour toujours
à terme ou est ce qu'on veut et si
demain monsieur le premier ministre la
turquie où nos amis kurdes nous renvoie
des tueurs de dèche et que ces tueurs
sont défendus est logique par des
avocats qui diront mais au moment où ils
ont commis des crimes ou des massacres
il était sous l'effet de drogues
il était sous l'effet d'embrigadement il
n'avait pas alors leur pleine conscience
jusqu'où va-t-on légitimer la violence
le risque pour la république je ne vous
demande pas monsieur le premier ministre
une réponse remettant en cause la
magistrature loin s'en faut et je
respecte le travail des magistrats mais
je vous dit le gouvernement la
république se doit de protéger tous les
français
[Applaudissements]
et la parole mais qu'à notre collègue
philippe bonnecarrère pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
madame la ministre à battre le chef
militaire d'un pays souverain
l'iran sur le territoire de notre pays
souverain l'irak n'a pas été une mince
décision attiser les nationalismes
iranien ou irakiens ne l'est pas plus
qu'en gronde les crises tout
interconnecté du liban à la syrie de
l'irak au yémen ou encore du détroit
d'ormuz à l'afghanistan
madame des ministres quelle est votre
analyse quelle est l'analyse du
gouvernement sur les frappes de cette
nuit
quelles sont les priorités de la france
quelles sont les priorités de l'europe
notre pays peut-il contribuer à la
désescalade voire à la médiation et
comment pouvons-nous poursuivre la lutte
contre l'état islamique et éviter que
les braises se rallume merci de votre
attention de vos réponses pour vous
répondre
la parole les lava secrétaire d'état
recherche d interrompre elle-même de
montchanin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur permettez moi tout d'abord
d'excusés jean yves le drian qui est
actuellement en egypte pour continuer à
oeuvrer à la sécurité et la stabilité
régionales en coordination avec
d'ailleurs nos partenaires européens
il ya aujourd'hui une situation de crise
grave qui concerne directement la
sécurité des français et le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères l'a
dit ce matin
nous condamnons les attaques conduites
cette nuit par l'iran en irak contre des
emprises de la coalition contre dèche
je le rappelle cette coalition contre
dèche existe depuis 2014 elle réunit
plus de 70 pays et organisations
internationales
elle a été installée à la demande des
autorités irakiennes pour combattre en
irak et en syrie des ch
elle a eu des résultats importants
notamment la fin du califat territoriale
en 2019 en mars 2019
mais nous savons cette menace peut
ressurgir alors notre priorité
aujourd'hui plus que jamais c'est bien
la désescalade
parce que ce cycle de violence doit
s'interrompre et la france est en
contact avec l'ensemble des parties
concernées plus de 20 chefs d'état 20
minutes affaires étrangères des états
unis de la chine la russie l'arabie
saoudite les émirats arabes unis l'inde
l'allemagne
bien sûr l'union européenne tant que
tels l'italie le royaume-uni le danemark
ou encore l'irak ont été contactés par
jean yves le drian ou président
république dans les derniers jours nous
avons avec toutes ces parties concernées
puissent oeuvrer à encourager la retenue
et la responsabilité des consultations
ayant eu lieu ont eu lieu hier à
bruxelles vendredi se tiendra un conseil
des affaires étrangères extraordinaire
et notre vision est partagée car
personne n'a aujourd'hui intérêt à un
conflit
nous devons plus que jamais combattre
dèche encore et toujours
nous devons protéger nos ressortissants
nous devons poursuivre cette lutte
contre donc des ch et nous devons
troisième priorité éviter une crise de
prolifération nucléaire c'est pourquoi
nous parlons à tout le monde et que nous
appelons toutes les parties à la retenue
je vous remercie monsieur wenger r oui
madame la ministre
au risque d'être un peu solennel
premièrement la crise au moyen-orient
nous interpelle dans notre souveraineté
française comme dans les souveraineté de
l'europe et pour moi ce sont les mêmes
sujets deuxièmement nous devons garder
le cap de la lutte contre le terrorisme
que ce soit ici au bas de l'immeuble au
coin du parc comme nous l'avons entendu
il ya quelques secondes ou bien entendu
au moyen orient
et troisièmement la décision d'abattre
le général souleiman était nous nous
trompons pas une décision électorale de
politique intérieure américaine et aux
risques je l'indiquais d'être un peu
solennel nous n'avons pas me semble-t-il
à un être les supplétifs ni deux ni
aujourd'hui ni demain
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
michel amiel pour le groupe de la
république en mars
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des solidarités et de la
santé madame la ministre une once de
solidarité dans ce monde de brutalité
d'égoïsme tout simplement les appareils
auditifs les lunettes de vue ou encore
les couronnes dentaires
autant ne soit indispensable pour
beaucoup de français qui leur était
pourtant parfois inaccessibles certains
soins représente des coûts exorbitants
si l'on doit compter de 500 à 900 euros
pour une couronne en céramique le reste
à charge varient entre 200 et 500 euros
après remboursement bien sûr de
l'assurance maladie c'est pourquoi
nombre de français renoncent à se
soigner
si le reste à charge des ménages étaient
près de trois fois plus élevé en
proportion que pour les autres postes de
soins ils représentaient 25 % de leurs
dépenses en soins prothétiques dentaire
et 56% pour les aides auditives 22% en
optique
depuis le 1er janvier cette situation
dans le pays comme la france n'est plus
la réforme 100% santé appelées également
rsa charge zéro mise en place
progressivement depuis janvier d'une
minute dix neuf jusqu'en 2021 propose un
ensemble de prestations de soins
d'équipement dans un panier spécifique
pour ces trois postes de soins
cette réforme poursuit ainsi son
déploiement cette année encore avec une
deuxième étape engagé aujourd'hui nous
permettons à nos concitoyens de
bénéficier d'une prise en charge à 100 %
sur leurs dépenses de lunettes et sur
les soins dentaires les plus courants
permettre l'accès à la santé pour tous
et j'en suis sûr un objectif communément
partagée sur les bancs de notre haute
assemblée alors madame la ministre
permettez moi de vous demander quelle
sera la suite de la mise en oeuvre pour
une montée en charge complète de cette
réforme ô combien importante et soutenue
par les français pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre des
solidarités la santé en allemagne est
d'usagé
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur michel hamel
d'abord merci pour votre question parce
que vous avez raison beaucoup de
citoyens ont dû renoncer à des soins
pour des raisons financières
nous savons que deux tiers des
malentendants aujourd'hui ne sont pas
équipés nous savons que 17% des français
renoncent aux soins dentaires en raison
du reste à charge et cette situation
n'était plus acceptable
les soins dentaires les lunettes les
appareils auditifs n'ont rien de
superflu
ils sont essentiels à la vie quotidienne
la réforme du champ % santé a été
élaborée conjointement avec les
professionnels des différents secteurs
et les complémentaires il s'agit d'un
progrès majeur depuis le 1er janvier
le 100% santé est entrée en vigueur en
optique
grâce à cette offre changer de lunettes
sur prescription médicale est désormais
totalement remboursé l'offre concerne
les montures comme les verts avec des
équipements de qualité des verres
antireflet anti-rayures amincie les
actes dentaires les plus courants les
couronnes et bridges sont désormais pris
en charge à 100% avec le remboursement
intégral de 8 prothèse dit fixe elles
seront prises en charge
avant les prothèses mobiles seront pris
en charge l'un des prochaines 1er
janvier 2021
enfin dans le domaine de l'audiologie en
2018 les patients devaient assumer des
frais de 850 euros par oreille en
moyenne en 2019 le reste à charge a
baissé de 200 euros en moyenne
cette année encore ils baissent de 250
euros supplémentaires
et l'année prochaine les prothèses
auditives seront totalement prise en
charge pour tous les français qui ont
accès aujourd'hui les dentistes et
opticiens les audioprothésistes doivent
c'est une obligation les informer de
l'offre 100% tenté dans un devis qui
doivent être remis il s'agit d'une
réforme majeure qui n'avait que trop
tardé je voulais c est sûr mieux
la parole est à notre collègue joël
labbé pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole vous chers collègues
si monsieur le président une question à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
sur le ministre on connaît votre intérêt
pour les plantes médicinales et leur
usage à la fois traditionnel et innovant
ma question porte sur un de ces usages
particulièrement intéressant pour la
transition de notre agriculture
vous le savez la loi d'avenir agricole a
permis aux agriculteurs d'utiliser pour
les plantes alimentaires les huiles
essentielles en tant que substance
naturelle à usage de bio stimulant via
la réglementation sur les pnpp
préparations naturelles peu
préoccupantes
c'est une réelle avancée car il est
absurde d'exiger une autorisation de
mise sur le marché pour des produits par
ailleurs vendu comme aliments et la
santé des plantes par les plantes plutôt
que par les pesticides de synthèse
c'est une belle opportunité pour
l'agroécologie et aussi pour l'économie
des territoires ruraux
or de récentes déclarations émanant de
votre ministère laissent entendre qu'un
nouvel arrêté pourrait exclure les
huiles essentielles des pnpp composé de
substances naturelles à usage de bio
stimulant elle serait alors soumise à de
coûteuses autorisation de mise sur le
marché en tant que pesticides
cela constituerait un recul
incompréhensible et mettre un coup
d'arrêt au développement de pratiques
vertueuses
de nombreux paysans utilisent des huiles
essentielles sur le terrain sans
qu'aucun problème sanitaire ne soit
constaté des pme développent des
produits innovants et des entreprises
agroalimentaires se tourner vers ces
alternatives à la chimie à monsieur le
ministre alors chacun reconnaît la
nécessité de réduire l'usagé des
pesticides de synthèse
pouvez vous nous confirmer que les
huiles essentielles resteront bien
considérés comme des préparations
naturelles peu préoccupantes pour vous
répondre la parole et au ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation se
dit
guillaume gavelle à paris monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur joël
labbé merci pour votre question nous
étions vus il ya pas longtemps vous avez
travaillé sur ces sujets depuis de
longues années depuis vous êtes sénateur
notamment sur l'art boris theuri sur
d'autres sur d'autres sujets à la fois
la loi d'avenir la loi et galim on
avancer dans cette direction à titre
personnel vous le savez je suis sûr
votre position
et je suis favorable à ce que les choses
puissent le faire mais la position du
gouvernement s'appuie sur deux sujets
sur la science et sur la transparence et
donc là ne cesse doit absolument rendre
son rapport aujourd'hui et des choses
qui sont dites que vous évoquez dans
votre dans votre question mais voilà
c'est des choses qui sont dites
s'élançait ce qui devra rendre son
rapport et qui devra dire la réalité
delà de la situation et parallèlement
évidemment le gouvernement mettra cela
en débat public il y aura un débat qui
sera mis qui sera mis sur la table et
qui permettra de 2 que chacun soit bien
ce soit bien informé la ville de seysses
chose cahier des charges il était
attendu pour fin mars
donc dans trois mois vous aurez là vous
aurez là la réponse est juste après nous
mettrons un arrêté de reconnaissance qui
est des charges
la consultation publique sera mis en
place juste après fin mars et la
parution le résultat sont rendus
vraisemblement d'ici l'été
donc voilà je pense que nous doit être
vigilant nous avons la même la même
vision on va attendre leur utah de
lancer la consultation publique et dans
les semaines qui viennent vous aurez la
réponse monsieur de sénateur je l'avais
dit loppsi la lecture l'écriture de
l'arrêté n'était pas satisfaisante
je peux vous faire savoir que ça va
bouger dans les campagnes et je ne serai
pas le dernier à organiser les
mobilisations
parce que y'en a véritablement marre de
cette situation ou des substances
naturelles sont contraintes au même
titre que les pesticides je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue pierre
laurent pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mes chers collègues madame la
ministre
l'engrenage militaire et guerrier tant
redouté entre les etats-unis et l'iran
est désormais enclenchée
l'irresponsabilité de donald trump est
immense
après avoir torpillé l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
il vient avec l'assassinât ciblé du
général soliman ni de faire le choix
délibéré d'attiser une nouvelle fois la
guerre dans la région
la riposte iranienne est la conséquence
programmée de cette logique de guerre
voulue par le président américain et le
feu vert donné à l'offensive turque en
syrie est peut-être très bientôt en
libye n'était qu'un sinistre prélude la
logique américaine et manifestement
celle de la guerre sans fin au
moyen-orient les guerres s'enchaînent
depuis 30 ans et aucun des conflits ne
sait réellement achevée sans que ne
s'ouvre un nouveau front augmentant sans
cesse les destructions de cette société
cette logique vient de surcroît de
réaliser le tour de force de ressouder
la population derrière le régime
autoritaire des mollahs en iran ont
reléguant au second plan les puissants
mouvements de protestation populaire qui
en irak en iran et au liban cherche des
voies de justice et de démocratie
nouvelle la france madame la ministre ne
doit pas se laisser entraîner dans cette
logique
la france ne peut pas s'en tenir à des
déclarations appelant à la désescalade
sans situer les responsabilités
sans condamner fermement l'initiative
illégales prises par en trope est
d'ailleurs largement condamné aux états
unis
j'ai trois questions précise madame la
ministre premièrement la france exclut
t-elle réellement tout engagement
militaire supplémentaire qui emboîterait
le pas aux américains
deuxièmement est il exact que dans les
contacts dans l'otan et dans la
conversation téléphonique entre le
président de la république et donald
trump
la france a assuré le président
américain de son plein soutien dans
cette affaire troisième question en tout
état de cause
le gouvernement et je m'adresse on cela
aussi au premier ministre est il prêt à
titre exceptionnel et compte tenu de la
gravité du moment présent à saisir le
parlement par une déclaration avec vote
si la question se pose est d'autoriser
ou non un engagement des forces eu un
engagement supplémentaire d'air
militaire française aux côtés des forces
de l'otan quand vous répondre la parole
et à madame de montchalin secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président monsieur
c'est à tort laurent ce qui est engagé
aujourd'hui c'est bien au fond le
résultat d'une mauvaise réaction
iranienne
en réponse à une mauvaise décision
américaine de sortir de l'accord du
nucléaire de 2015 discipline et
d'imposer une logique de sanction
maximale nous l'avons dit je leur dis si
nous ne soutenons pas cette décision
américaine qui date de mai 2018
nous avons alerté la communauté snal sur
les risques des mauvaises initiatives de
part et d'autre et des deux dès
septembre 2017 nous avions d'ailleurs
dit que le risque était bien celui d'une
escalade des tensions régionales et nous
avions engagé des initiatives pour une
nouvelle négociation globale qui
préserve l'accord nucléaire et le
complète par une négociation sur les
missiles et la stabilité régionale cette
mauvaise réaction iranienne s'est
traduite on le sait d'abord par des
violations successives de l'accord
nucléaire qui est aujourd'hui en danger
qui a été il a été vidé de sa substance
il ya eu ensuite des actions de
déstabilisation régionale qui ont été
conduites depuis six mois et donc ses
mauvaises décisions mène à la crise que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
c'est dans ce contexte que nous avons
dit qu'il était inacceptable que des
attaques soient conduites contre la
coalition qui luttent contre des ch et
contre des jeux seulement car la
poursuite de la lutte contre des jeux
lady est un impératif de sécurité pour
nous pour l'irak et pour la stabilité
régionale
et si nous avons une solidarité exprimée
elle est un endroit des partenaires de
cette coalition contre dèche
parce que des emprises ont été attaqués
parce que cette coalition qui lutte
contre le terrorisme a été attaqué
ce titre est à ce titre seulement que
nous sommes solidaires car je le
distingue très précisément de l'action
américaine contre le général souleymane
sy qui n'est pas une action de la
coalition contre dèche
elle a été décidé sans consultation la
france par les états unis sur la base de
considérations de sécurité nationale et
c'est donc une initiative américaine et
de leur seule responsabilité
alors la priorité absolue monsieur le
sénateur est effectivement n'est pas
d'engager nouvelle force elle n'est pas
de rentrer dans une logique d escalade
mais bien d'appeler la démocratie et
notamment avec nos partenaires européens
à la dsca laddh à la retenue et la
responsabilité je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue pascal
allizard pour le groupe l'est
républicain sur l'isr monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
effectivement depuis plusieurs mois la
tension monte entre l'iran et les états
unis discours défiant la communauté
internationale violation des traités
internationaux
tweet vindicatif autant qu'ils
responsable nous assistons je crois à la
diplomatie l'agonie de la diplomatie
internationale face à une politique
unilatérale américaine politique un peu
du coup de menton je suis désolé de le
dire sur les réseaux sociaux qui conduit
je crois à une impasse comme
l'illustrent l'exemple de la corée du
nord poursuivant ses programmes
militaires
certes inquiet du contexte économique et
social de notre pays
les français n'en sont pas moins
préoccupé des questions internationales
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs des incendies
en amazonie en australie ou de
l'intensification du programme nucléaire
iranien
nos citoyens sont concernés
avec l'élimination du général souleymane
sy par une frappe américaine puis la
riposte de téhéran sur deux bases où
sont stationnés des soldats américains
en irak
la région est plongée dans une escalade
des plus dangereuses la crise iranienne
n'est qu'un des volets d'une situation
générale au proche et moyen-orient
profondément dégradée sur laquelle
finalement nous avons peu de prise
pourtant jadis la voix de la france
porte et influer sur le cours des
événements la crise syrienne a montré
que cela n'était plus
le cas dès lors madame la ministre
comment comptez vous ramener la
diplomatie française et européenne dans
le jeu et alors que le président
américain vient de tweets et il ya
quelques minutes avoir l'armé la plus
puissante et la mieux équipée du monde
menace d'ailleurs déjà servi aux nord
coréens pour le résultat que l'on
connaît
il est primordial que la france mobilise
ses partenaires européens et les alliés
pour parvenir à la désescalade
comment comptez vous mêmes la ministre
assurer la stabilité régionale de même
que la sécurité des militaires français
encore engagés dans la lutte contre
d'âge et la formation des forces
irakiennes qui est l'une des clés de la
stabilisation de l'état irakien au
répandre la parole est à madame de mon
chemin vers la page merci monsieur le
président monsieur sénateurs à lisa
d'abord effectivement vous le dites avec
réseau notre priorité est bien la
sécurité de nos ressortissants de nos
militaires nous avons pris des mesures
de vigilance renforcée dès vendredi
dernier et à nouveau s'agissant en
particulier de l'iran et l'irak
hier vous m'interrogez sur les efforts
que nous menons que jean yves le drian
mène avec le présent la république et
tout gouvernement notamment au niveau
européen pour assurer la sécurité et la
stabilité régionale hier se tenait à
bruxelles
des réunions réunissant le royaume uni
l'italie l'allemagne et la france autour
du représentant européen joseph bourrel
qui ont concerné à la fois bien sûr est
question iranienne et irakienne est
également le sujet libyen qui nous le
savons est aussi inquiétant aujourd'hui
un collège spécial des commissaires
européens se réunissaient autour de
josette borel et 12 ou l'iphone l'iphone
pourrait également aborder cette
question et dès vendredi
josep borrell a convoqué un conseil des
affaires étrangères extraordinaire où là
aussi nous pourrons en européen poser un
diagnostic
regardez la situation en europe et 1 et
regarder que ce que nous pouvons faire
dorénavant pour notamment pesé pesé pour
effectivement amené à la désescalade la
médiation que ce soit sur l'accord de
vienne est la suite et la survie de
l'accord dit du cyprès deviennent début
ce qui avait été tentée à biarritz puis
aux nations unies tous ces moments sont
des moments où nous montrons que le
multilatéralisme n'est pas un vain mot
le fait même que nous ayons des tables
négociation des tables de discussion le
fait même que jean yves le drian soit
aujourd'hui en egypte à nouveau pour
échanger sur la stabilité régionale et
de la bassin méditerranée orientale sont
des preuves que nous sommes à la
manoeuvre
vingt pays je les divins partenaires ont
été mobilisés par le président la
république et par jean yves le drian
depuis vendredi ces 20 pays nous ont
tous dit la même chose
nous partageons votre vision voulons la
désescalade
nous n'avons aucune intérêt conflit et
donc notre action principale consiste à
rappeler les priorités la désescalade à
court terme la peau lutte contre des shu
le terrorisme
car partout et toujours cela peut
ressurgir et enfin la protection contre
la prolifération nucléaire qui est là
aussi un enjeu sur lequel vous savez
nous sommes pleinement engagés je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue jean luc
fichet pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain sur collègue monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
les personnels hospitaliers sont
mobilisés depuis des mois maintenant
pour défendre l'accès aux soins et leurs
conditions d'exercice les expriment
collectivement une vraie souffrance au
travail
récemment les internes ont choisi de
rejoindre le mouvement qui s'intensifie
dans mon département du finistère des
praticiens refusent leur nouvelle
assignation
après avoir effectué 62 heures de
travail dans la semaine la formation des
futurs médecins véritablement dégradée
au vu des conditions dans lesquelles ils
exercent l'hôpital public se meurt c'est
en ces termes que 660 médecins menaçant
de démissionner vous ont alerté dans
leur tribune parue le 15 décembre
dernier
madame la ministre ils sont aujourd'hui
mille signataires les annonces de votre
gouvernement fin novembre non
visiblement convaincu personne
nous avons la chance de disposer d'un
système de soin parmi les meilleurs au
monde est une organisation de notre
système de santé qui nous est enviée
nous nous devons de le préserver et de
travailler à le faire évoluer
positivement les médecins les infirmiers
les aides-soignants et l'ensemble des
personnels des hôpitaux vous le demande
investissez réellement dans l'hôpital
public
madame la ministre ma question est donc
simple avez vous un vrai projet d'avenir
pour l'hôpital public
quels sont les moyens que vous allez
réellement consacré pour que chaque
citoyen français est taxé à services de
santé allez vous oui ou non
revaloriser les salaires du secteur
allez-vous mettre un terme à la
politique de fermetures de lits et
augmenter les effectifs des personnels
hospitaliers
il y à véritablement urgence je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole de
kavo l'amabilité solidarité de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean luc fichet je crois que
nous poursuivons tous le même objectif
d'abord garantir l'accès aux soins à des
soins de qualité pour tous les français
dans tous les territoires à la campagne
à la ville et le secteur public
hospitalier est évidemment une
préoccupation que nous partageons nous
savons aussi les attentes des soignants
nous les connaissons celle des soignants
celle des patients celle des élus que
vous représentez et qui ont tous une
inquiétude vis-à-vis de notre système de
santé qui a été en fait mis à mal par un
désinvestissement depuis de nombreuses
années vous le savez et un manque de
médecins liés à une politique de numerus
clausus beaucoup trop restreinte dans
les années 90 et 2000 dont nous payons
le prix aujourd'hui
faute de pouvoir recruter des soignants
et de pavant des médecins dans beaucoup
d'établissements dès mon arrivée j'ai
travaillé un plan global de
transformation de notre système de santé
à la fois pour faire évoluer la médecine
de ville et lutter contre la
désertification médicale à la fois pour
redonner envie aux soignants d'exercer
notamment à l'hôpital public en
améliorant la qualité de vie au travail
et on améliorera aussi les rémanents les
rémunérations vis-à-vis de certains
engagements je pense à des protocoles de
coopération par exemple je pense aux
aides soignantes en gériatrie qui
reçoivent toute une prime aujourd'hui
200 euros nets par mois
cela représente 40 mille personnes
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont accès à cette
prime
et puis j'ai souhaité réinvestir dans
l'hôpital public c'est le plan qui a été
présenté par monsieur le premier
ministre il y a deux mois qui visent à
réinvestir non seulement avec des
budgets en hausse depuis cette année et
sur lequel nous avons pris un engagement
de budget en hausse dans les trois ans
qui viennent avec de la visibilité et
une reprise partielle de la dette des
hôpitaux qui va être une bouffée d'air
pour les établissements de façon à
pouvoir rpt et employé plus de personnel
et réouvrir délit puisque c'était votre
question car il n'y a pas de politique
volontaire de fermetures de lits dans
notre pays bien au contraire
ensuite une série de mesures ne suffit
pas il faut la totalité des mesures qui
doivent se déployer et elle commence dès
ce mois ci grâce aux votes du plfss
je pense par exemple un plan
d'investissement particulier sur
l'investissement courant ces mesures se
déploient
j'en suis garante et je veux montrer aux
personnels qu'elles sont concrètes et
rapides
je vous remets vieux fichiers vous avez
quelques secondes à merci madame la
ministre je crois malgré tout que ces
mesures soient homéopathiques et que le
résultat soit quasi nul
il y à véritablement urgence penser aux
mille médecins qui menacent de
démissionner merci merci la parole est à
notre collègue hester d'hitler pour le
groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur dans la nuit du
31 décembre au 1er janvier
des voitures ont brûlé dans de très
nombreuses villes en france cela devient
une tradition révoltante qu'il est
urgent d'endiguer à strasbourg la
situation était particulièrement tendue
le maire estime à 220 le nombre de
voitures brûlées et les policiers ont
été bien sûr pris pour cible je viens de
m'entretenir avec les responsables du
sdiss du bas-rhin ce qu'ont vécu les
pompiers ce soir la donne une idée du
niveau de violence dans certains
quartiers et du niveau de rennes chez
certains de nos concitoyens à 2 heures
du matin les sapeurs-pompiers ont fait
face à une violence jusqu'ici inédite
dans la cité nucléaire l'une des plus
importantes de strasbourg les jeunes
assaillants luron les termes en
littéralement tendu un guet-apens aux
moyens de
rage constituées de poubelles en flammes
les pompiers raconte qu ils ont été
encerclés
le but étant de les lyncher un sapeur
pompier a reçu un projectile à la tête
qu'il aurait à coup sûr tuer s'il
n'avait pas eu de casques sans la
dextérité du chauffeur du camion
l'équipage à l'intérieur aurait été
agressée est assailli il ne s'agissait
plus seulement de casser du matériel
mais de s'en prendre physiquement aux
équipages
les sapeurs-pompiers ont témoigné de la
préméditation de ces agressions qui ont
d'ailleurs été filmée par ces voyez-vous
monsieur miss monsieur le ministre je
vous mets en garde
les propose indignés ne suffiront plus
les condamnations journal de 20h non
plus il faut ouvrir les yeux et nous
dire ce que vous comptez faire pour que
ces nuits de violence ne se reproduise
plus comment comptez vous protéger nos
pompiers
comment comptez vous reconquérir ces
enclaves qui échappe à la république et
qui sont minés par le communautarisme
par ailleurs pouvez vous nous dire
combien de voitures en france ont brûlé
dans la nuit de la saint sylvestre
les français ont le droit de savoir et
les élus ont besoin de connaître la
réalité chiffrée la presse ce matin
parlait de 1457 voitures brûlées + 13 %
par rapport à l'an passé
pouvez vous nous le confirmer j'attends
dans votre réponse en chiffres précis au
conclure ce n'est pas en taxant le
problème que vous règlerez le 2e voulu
régler pour vous répondre
la parole est comme celui liste de
l'intérieur au soutien scolaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice non j'ai fait le choix
l'année dernière je leur fais cette
année de ne pas commenter le chiffre des
voitures brûlées comme mon prédécesseur
brice hortefeux d'ailleurs qui encore ce
matin dans les médias évoqué une
décision simple et intelligente qui est
fondée sur le fait d'éviter que le
concours imbécile de quelques abrutis
qui trouve logique d'incendié les
voitures dans leur propre quartier de
leurs voisins de leurs amis comme une
sorte de concours entre quartiers entre
communes entre départements soit
alimenté soit alimenté justement par le
commentaire des chiffres mais ça n'est
pas pour cacher la vérité parce que la
vérité c'est celle que vous avez madame
la sénatrice évoqué c'est celle de ces
violences insupportables
inax
club et en particulier à strasbourg et
autour de strasbourg qui a été cette
année et votre question le montre bien
je vous le confirme un des lieux où le
niveau de violence a été le plus élevé
globalement les violences contre les
forces de sécurité intérieure le 31
décembre
mais il est vrai qu'à strasbourg ça
avait débuté dès le 30 mai le 31
décembre ont diminué de près de 50%
cette année partout en france mais le
nombre de voitures lui effectivement
reste cette espèce de concours que j'ai
dénoncée dans mon propos liminaire ceux
qui comptent madame la sénatrice c'est
de constater aussi le niveau
d'engagement de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure près de 290 hommes avaient
été mobilisés à strasbourg en plus de
celles et ceux qui sont habituellement
engagés sur le terrain pour essayer
d'être présent partout sur le territoire
de strasbourg de la même façon partout
en france ce sont près de dix mille
hommes
le même niveau que l'année dernière qui
ont été engagées au titre des gendarmes
et des policiers près de 15000 femmes et
hommes ont été engagées avec les
sapeurs-pompiers et nous devons
renforcer selon coe raison pour laquelle
le président de la république et nous
nous sommes engagés à lancer un plan de
recrutement de près de dix mille
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
et vous le savez ils sont présents jour
et nuit et n'y a pas de 31 décembre il
n'y a pas de nos ali sont sur le terrain
et nous devons aussi sécurisé l'action
de nos sapeurs pompiers et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai souhaité que
des conventions locales de sécurité
soient établies partout dans tous les
quartiers difficiles pour que à aucun
moment il n'est intervenir sans être
protégé par les forces de sécurité
intérieure en deux minutes
je ne peux pas répondre à toutes vos
questions mais vous avez raison nous
devons mener un débat un combat mètre
carré par mètre carré pour que la
république soit partout chez elle
la parole est à notre collègue jean
marie bockel pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
hall madame la garde des sceaux
s'agissant de la décision d'
irresponsabilité pénale par la cour
d'appel de paris de l'auteur de
l'assassinât à la fois infâme et
antisémite de gisèle halimi la question
pertinente de roger karoutchi et la
réponse du premier ministre précise en
l'état du droit sont un élément
important du débat
reste une question que faire que faire
aujourd'hui pour que le grand rabbin de
france à une korcia ne soient plus
obligés de déclarer de le site devrait
on en déduire que tout individu drogué
seraient dotées d'un permis de tuer les
juifs mais c'est vrai aussi pour les
meurtres dans les églises dans tout
autre lieu de culte pour les actes et
crimes terroristes
que faire pour que la famille halimi
demain d'autres familles ne soient pas
privés d'un procès public
alors évidemment loin de supprimer le
principe d'irresponsabilité pénale
incontestable et sans remettre en cause
bien sûr l'indépendance de la justice
ne pourrait-on pas par la loi préciser
la portée et les conséquences pour
éviter de telles situations notamment
pour ce type de faits de manière à ce
qu'il puisse y avoir une décision
d'irresponsabilité lorsqu'elle doit être
prises elles le soient dans un procès
public et contradictoire
je vous remercie madame la garde des
sceaux de votre réponse pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame lagarde
saut du lit de la justice madame b to b
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
c'est un prix spécial sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur bockel nous avons tous été
extrêmement touché par le meurtre de
madame attal halimi et je comprends bien
évidemment les mois que cela a suscité à
l'issue de l'instruction je voudrais ici
rappeler précisément ce qui s'est passé
juridiquement à l'issue de l'instruction
une audience s'est tenue devant la cour
d'appel de
harry portant sur la question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale de l'accusé en
raison de troubles psychiques
je voudrais rappeler comme l'a fait
monsieur le premier ministre à l'instant
que au terme de cette audience les juges
sont expressément retenu le caractère
antisémite du meurtre de madame aline
cette audience s'est déroulée dans le
cadre d'une procédure qui a été mise en
oeuvre par une loi de 2008
dans ce cadre elle a permis à l'ensemble
des parties de débattre publiquement et
contradictoirement sur la question des
expertises qui avait subi l'accusé six
experts psychiatres sur sept ont
considéré que l'accusé était
irresponsable au moment des faits et que
son discernement était aboli la cour a
effectivement suivi ces expertises et
elle a estimé que le suspect ne pouvait
être condamné pénalement
comme la loi le permet la cour a ordonné
que le suspect un soit hospitalisé
d'office de lui a interdit d'entrer en
contact avec la famille pendant une
durée de 20 ans je sais que cette
décision n'a pas été comprise par les
parties civiles et en raison notamment
de l'appréciation qui a été faite de
l'état psychiatrique de l'intéressé en
raison de sa consommation préalable est
prolongée de cannabis et donc je suis
certaine que nous sommes là face à une
situation juridique complexe est inédite
et je crois que à ce niveau la cour de
cassation apportera toutes les réponses
juridiques nécessaires puisqu'elle a été
saisie par les parties civiles d'un
pourvoi en cassation
je soulignerai simplement pour terminer
que sur le plan procédural
la loi de 2008 a apporté une réponse aux
victimes puisqu'elle met en place je le
répète une audience publique et
contradictoire et je voudrais terminer
en disant que ce débat public et
contradictoire a été rendue possible
sans remettre en cause un principe
cardinal de notre droit pénal qui figure
en france depuis le code napoléon
et comme dans tous les autres états de
droit principe cardinal selon lesquelles
on ne juge pas dans un état de droit les
malades mentaux
[Musique]
monsieur bockel merci madame la garde
des sceaux pour votre réponse précise et
étayer cela dit dans le strict respect
de l'indépendance de la justice
repréciser le principe
d'irresponsabilité pénale par la loi ou
la jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
peu importe permettrait de ne pas priver
les familles les victimes
et finalement la nation tout entière
notamment dans le cas de tels actes
antisémites terroriste d'un procès la
parole est à notre collègue jean raymond
hugonnet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre la
liberté d'aller et venir est une
composante fondamentale de la liberté
individuelle chacun peut circuler sur
l'ensemble du territoire national dès
lors qu'il y ait régulièrement entrée en
voilà maintenant plus d'un mois que la
sncf et la ratp ne sont plus en capacité
d'assurer normalement leur mission de
service public avec bruno retailleau et
de très nombreux collègues nous
proposons la création d'un véritable
service minimum de transport garanties
applicables à l'ensemble des transports
publics
ce service minimum garanti ne remet pas
en cause le droit de grève
il propose simplement d'aménager son
exercice à l'instar de ce que prévoit
déjà la loi pour d'autres services
publics comme les hôpitaux ou la
télévision publique
il s'inscrit clairement dans une
jurisprudence bien établie du conseil
constitutionnel mais ce n'est pas tout
cette proposition de loi prévoit
également de simplifier les démarches
des usagers dont le voyage est annulé
afin qu'ils ne soient plus pénalisés
financièrement
elle interdit en effet l'avoir
actuellement scandaleusement mis en
place au profit d'un remboursement
direct notons d'ailleurs au passage que
la sncf est plus à l'aise avec le
siphonnage de nos cartes bleues qu'avec
le respect de ses horaires
j'ajoute enfin que valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france
demande à juste titre depuis plusieurs
semaines et dans le même esprit le
remboursement intégral du passe navigo
pour tous les jours de grève
monsieur le ministre il est de votre
responsabilité de prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent pour en finir avec
l'insupportable triptyque pagaille
raquette et escroquerie que comptez vous
faire concrètement pour vous répondre la
parole et au secrétaire d'état en charge
des transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur hugonnet je veux d'abord appelé
le cadre de la loi bertrand qui a été
posée en 2007 et qui impose aux
grévistes de se déclarer 48 heures à l
avance de manière à organiser le plan de
transport et de manière à ce que les
usagers puissent anticiper au mieux leur
déplacement
cette loi bertrand elle a certainement
atteint quelques limites parce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
contourner au sein des entreprises c'est
notamment le cas des grèves de 59
minutes ou qui sont très déstabilisante
pour l'organisation du travail ou encore
de préavis illimité qui sont validées
par les juges le dispositif a
certainement atteint quelques limites et
le gouvernement est prêt sur ces sujets
à en tirer les conséquences en lien avec
les entreprises concernées sur le sujet
du service minimum
après à proprement parler que vous
évoquez vous savez très bien que la
proposition qui a été faite dans vos
rangs et inopérante en l'état et que par
ailleurs elle a été formulée un peu
opportunément quelques jours avant le
début de la grève
dès lors je tiens à rappeler ceci qu à
droit constant
l'état est parfaitement fondé à agir dès
lors que les français sont durablement
empêché de se déplacer dès lors que les
besoins essentiels de la nation ne sont
plus satisfaits
dès lors que l'activité économique et
social et durablement entravé et que
nous avons par ailleurs toujours dit que
le gouvernement était attentif à la
séquence qui se passait et qu'ils en
tiraient éventuellement les compléments
aux dispositifs existants à l'aide de
mesures à l'aide de mesures qu'ils
soient opérationnels et efficaces et je
tiens à prendre le temps en tout cas
l'opportunité pour saluer les agents de
la sncf et de la ratp les dizaines de
milliers d'agents à vrai dire la très
grande majorité des agents de la sncf et
de la ratp qui depuis le 5 décembre tous
les jours tous les jours sont au travail
dans des conditions difficiles et
transportent des millions de français en
sécurité monsieur gaudin oui monsieur le
ministre sauf votre respect tout cela ce
sont des confettis de parole la réalité
c'est que nos concitoyens sont exaspérés
et que si vous êtes fondée à agir alors
agissez parce qu'il en est temps nous ne
pouvons plus et les français également
merci la parole est à notre collègue
stéphane artano pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
la part eau merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
saint pierre et miquelon et doté d'un
régime de retraite applicable aux
salariés du secteur privé datant de 1987
et qui pour tenir compte des
spécificités locales liées au climat
s'est progressivement écartés du droit
commun l' ordonnance du 23 juillet 2015
pourtant réforme de l'assurance
vieillesse à saint pierre et miquelon
prévoit un alignement complet avec le
régime national en 2033 l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à la retraite et
progressivement relevé de 60 à 62 ans la
durée de référence pour l'obtention du
taux plein est progressivement allongé
et porté au niveau national en 2033 172
trimestres pour la génération 1960 13 le
calcul du revenu annuel moyen sera
effectuée sur la base des 25 meilleures
années et non plus sur la totalité de la
carrière
ce sera effectif en 2022 malgré la
volonté d' alignement progressif des
taux de cotisation les spécificités de
notre régime de retraite de base ont été
maintenus afin d'assurer une transition
plus douce vers le régime général
la loi du 28 février 2017 a mis en place
de financements pérennes de la prise en
charge pour la retraite des périodes de
chômage saisonnier pour les salariés de
certains secteurs d'activité comme le
btp ont raison des conditions
climatiques particulières 3 décembre
dernier j'ai interrogé le haut
commissaire sur l'application du projet
de réforme des retraites à saint pierre
et miquelon au regard de notre cadre
actuel à ce jour je n'ai obtenu aucune
réponse pourtant les conséquences
peuvent être importantes pour mes
compatriotes
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
préciser les intentions du goût
moment sur les conditions d'application
de son projet de réforme des retraites à
saint pierre et miquelon ton pour les
entreprises que pour les salariés
pour vous répondre là par les deux
secrétaires d'état charge des retraites
monsieur b 3f qui vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur artano alors effectivement vous
appeler mon attention sur la situation
particulière de l'assurance vieillesse
sur ce répertoire que vous connaissez
bien à saint pierre et miquelon vous
avez rappelé d'ailleurs que le régime
des assurés de ce territoire est en ce
moment même en cours de convergence avec
le régime général tant en matière
d'ailleurs d'âge de départ que de durée
nécessaire pour valider l'auto plaint
que de calculs sur la base des 25
meilleures années
les modalités de cette convergence ont
été définis de manière relativement
récente puisque c'est une ordonnance du
23 juillet 2015 et un décret de 2017 qui
sont venus les préciser cette
convergence sera pour certains de ses
paramètres achevée en 2025
à l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau système
de retraite universel
je tiens à vous rassurer ce que je crois
que c'était l'objet de votre question le
calendrier prévu de cette convergence ne
sera pas remise en cause
et comme cela avait été annoncé dans le
rapport le jean paul delevoye une
ordonnance viendra préciser les
modalités d'adaptation du système
universel aux caractéristiques et
contraintes particulières du territoire
de votre collectivité et je voudrais
relever une spécificité que vous avez
également évoqué dans votre question
celle qui concerne le fait que certains
salariés notamment issus des secteurs de
la pêche de l'agriculture et du btp voir
leurs allocations chômage prise en
compte dans leur revenu de référence
pour les interruptions d'activité
intervenant chaque année lors des
périodes climatiques difficiles je
rappelle que ce principe deviendra la
règle dans le cadre du système universel
puisque les périodes de chômage
indemnisées donneront systématiquement
droit à points ce sera donc le cas
également pour vous
merci monsieur à l'eau merci monsieur le
ministre je retiens vos enfants votre
attention quand même sur le fait que le
renvoi des ordonnances et une même
pratique pour adapter est spécifiquement
des textes à saint pierre et miquelon
ça a été un vrai fiasco sur la formation
professionnelle adoptée en septembre
2018 le pr la loi ne rentrera en vigueur
chez nous en 2021 et encore grâce à la
volonté de la collectivité dont j'ai
déjà tir votre attention sur le fait que
vous devez associer l'ensemble des
acteurs du territoire et anticiper les
éléments spécifiques que vous avez
mentionné tout à l'heure la parole est à
notre collègue jean yves le camp pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain mauvais
la parole ce président ma question
s'adresse madame amélie de montchanin
ministre secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes le 3 janvier dernier une
opération militaire décidée par le
président des états unis d'amérique tué
le général qasem soleimani sur le
territoire irakien
la mort de ce chef militaire et
responsables politiques iraniens par les
circonstances
par ces circonstances et parce qu'elle
représente est un vecteur de nouveaux
risques et drame dans la région et
l'alimentent la spirale des vengeances
chacun trouvant dans les actes de son
adversaire la justification de ses
engagements
les conséquences sont graves la
diplomatie visant à lutter contre la
prolifération nucléaire dont la cour de
2015 était un aboutissement exigeant en
particulier grâce à l'action de laurent
fabius est décrédibilisé l'iran qui
avait été le théâtre d'une répression
violente
inouï de l'expression de son peuple en
décembre voit les éléments les plus
extrêmes se renforcer dans le pays
enfin la réaction du parlement irakien
remet en cause les conditions de la
présence de la coalition internationale
de lutte contre l'état islamique car la
présence d'armées étrangères n'est plus
souhaitée par les autorités du pays
madame la ministre plusieurs questions
les états unis avaient il informé le
gouvernement français de leurs actions
du 3 janvier et de leurs objectifs
comment pourrions nous être solidaire
des états unis s'ils ne l'ont pas fait
les conditions de la lutte contre l'
état islamique
la situation des terroristes et de leurs
familles restées en irak sont
profondément modifiées
après cette action est la réaction des
autorités irakiennes comment ces
préoccupations peuvent elles être
poursuivis maintenant notre engagement
dans des circonstances nouvelles seront
elles soumises au parlement
comment pouvons nous considérer les
états unis comme des partenaires dans
cette lutte antiterroriste après ces
dernières semaines enfin la lumière de
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers ces
dernières heures
quelles mesures sont prises pour
prévenir la sécurité de nos
ressortissants dans la région
ceux qui y vivent et ceux qui voyagent
je vous remercie
amélie de moi je savais pour répondre à
la question monsieur le comte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur le compte alors je vais essayer
de répondre à vos questions en reprenant
des éléments que j'ai déjà pu évoquer
aujourd'hui
non nous n'avons pas été informés
puisqu'il s'agit d'une décision
américaine sur la base d'éléments de
sécurité nationale et c'est donc une
initiative américaine dont ils ont la
responsabilité
la solidarité je les dis aux sénateurs
le rompt la solidarité et celle avec nos
alliés de cette coalition contre des
camps des emprises de la coalition
contre la neige sont visés nous sommes
solidaires et je crois que toute
personne peut comprendre que nous sommes
à la demande des autorités irakiennes
dans une coalition qui réunit plus de 70
partenaires et organisations nationales
absolument engagées contre des neiges en
syrie en irak nous avons pu mettre fin
au khalifat territoriale nous avons pu
également arrêté la campagne de reprise
de territoire que souhaitaient les
terroristes nous savons que cette menace
reste extrêmement forte que nous devons
être extrêmement mobilisés et donc c'est
dans ce cadre que nous cherchons à
maintenir cette coalition contre lech
vivante nous avons dans les jours qui
viennent dans les semaines qui viennent
évidemment avec des autorités irakiennes
à dialogue leur souveraineté est à
préserver et les échanges qu'on jean
yves le drian a pu avoir d'ailleurs avec
le premier irakien montre bien que cette
lutte contre le terrorisme reste une
priorité pour tous sa présence
aujourd'hui en egypte d'ailleurs
contribuer à trouver les voies et moyens
pour poursuivre avec tous les acteurs
régionaux une lutte contre ce terrorisme
nos alliés vous le dites nos alliés sont
idéales et ce contre cette lutte contre
le terrorisme nous allier sont également
des alliés pour que nous arrivions à
lutter contre la prolifération nucléaire
ce sont là deux priorités essentielles
et vous pouvez bien comprendre la france
restera pleinement mobilisés sur ces
sujets quant à la sécurité de nos
ressortissants qu'ils soient civils ou
militaires je les dis nous avons engagé
dès vendredi dernier un plan sur le
terrain
les mesures ont été renforcées en iran
et en irak dans les dernières heures
nous suivons la situation très
attentivement et pour moi la clé c'est
la réunion maintenant qui se tiendra
vendredi de manière exceptionnelle à
bruxelles entre tous les ministres
affaires étrangères au tour de joseph
bourrel pour que nous puissions en
européen chercher la voie de la
désescalade de la lutte contre la
prolifération nucléaire et du maintien
d'une coalition forte contre le
terrorisme je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue martin berthet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues vous ne m'en voudrez pas
monsieur le ministre mais ma question
sur ce sujet des retraites qui agite et
inquiète notre pays tout entier
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre je n'irai
pas par quatre chemins votre réforme des
retraites est une mauvaise réforme
mauvaise parce que vous avez mis la
charrue avant les boeufs la priorité
aurait dû être de régler la question du
déficit mauvaise parce que les régimes
spéciaux en sortent renforcées alors
même que emmanuel macron le 4 octobre
dernier à rodez affirmait il n'y aura
plus de régimes spéciaux mauvaise parce
que votre système
au delà des discours dont on voit la
faible durée de vie va appauvrir les
retraités
le point est volatile les femmes et les
familles y perdront parfois beaucoup et
les pensions de réversion ne seront
versés qu'à 62 ans mauvaise parce qu à
des régimes différents vous substituer
une inégalité entre les générations
parce que les travailleurs indépendants
devront cotiser plus parce qu'il est
indispensable de maintenir nos régimes
complémentaires comme partout en europe
nous serions les seuls à avoir un régime
étatisé et unique
enfin
ce n'est pas le moindre parce que vous
sortez les plus hauts revenus d'un
système par répartition qui
contribuerait à assurer notre ciment
national alors n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment monsieur le premier ministre
qui lie à un fossé entre l'engagement
premier d'emmanuel macron de ne pas
toucher à l'âge légal les objectifs
affichés d'universalité et de justice et
la réalité des conséquences de votre
projet pour les français
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous avez votre avis sur ce projet de
réforme
il est tout à fait respectable sans
doute mais je voudrais vous indiqué
madame la sénatrice que aux termes du
projet que nous portons
si le parlement le vote bien entendu je
veux vous dire qu'il n'y aura plus de
régimes spéciaux de retraite et je veux
vous indiquer madame que vous le savez
d'ailleurs sans doute que depuis le 1er
janvier 2000 va il n'y a plus
d'embauchés au statut à la sncf vous
souvenez madame la sénatrice que quand
on nous avons fait cette réforme
certains nous disaient tout ça est une
petite réforme vous ne voulez pas
vraiment touché la gestion nous l'avons
fait madame la sénatrice et j'observe
que cela n'avait pas été fait auparavant
de la même façon pour le régime des
retraites le programme le problème
récurrent de l'equilibre de régimes de
retraite ce bail n'est pas nouveau il
est dans le système actuel
nous allons le régler car nous avons dit
qu un problème d'équilibré tu es un
problème sérieux dans un régime de
retraite quel qu'il soit et nous voulons
faire en sorte que ce régime soit
équilibré le futur régime comme le
régime actuel qu'il faut faire passer
originaux donc nous sommes attentifs et
attaché à la question de l' équilibre
nous voulons faire en sorte que le
système universel remplace la diversité
des systèmes existants
c'est vrai nous allons donc parce que
cela implique nécessairement supprimer
les régimes spéciaux
c'est un fait et croyez moi madame la
sénatrice en dépit de ce que vous dites
un certain nombre de
ceux qui sont soumis à ces régimes
spéciaux ou qui bénéficient de ces
régimes spéciaux ont bien compris le
message c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons
pour lesquelles ils protestent
on ne peut pas avoir d'un côté votre
discours disant il ne se passe rien de
l'autre le discours disant il se passe
tous vous voyez ce que je veux dire ça
montre que effectivement nous avançons
deuxième sujet vous dit que c'est une
mauvaise réforme
vous dites que c'est une mauvaise
réforme adam la sénatrice vous avez le
droit de le dire et j'espère que vous
lutterez de façon résolue contre le
minimum contributif à 1000 euros y
compris pour les agriculteurs les
artisans les indépendants 1000 euros de
minimum contributif j'espère que vous
dirai combien cette mesure est
scandaleuse combien elle représente un
déni de justice sociale par rapport à ce
qui prévalait jusqu'à présent j'espère
également madame la sénatrice que vous
indiquerez et que vous indiquerez
fortement à toutes celles et ceux qui
doivent aujourd'hui attendre 67 ans pour
liquider leur retraite sans décote
souvent des femmes et des hommes qui ont
des carrières hachées des carrières
difficile vous leur expliquerai que la
réforme que nous proposons est une
réforme qui fait moins de justice
sociale parce qu'ils pourront partir à
64 ans je crois à madame la sénatrice
que le débat qui nous réunira ici au
sénat à l'assemblée nationale d'abord
puis au sénat sur un débat passionnant
mais est ce qu'on peut avant l'examen
ici des dispositions précises qui seront
soumis aux parlementaires ne pas
s'envoyer à la figure des affirmations
qui sont bien souvent des affirmations
de posture là où même de postures je le
dis je le dis très tranquillement fond
me fait trop souvent ce reproche pour
que je m'interdise de le dire des
affirmations de posture alors que le
projet que nous allons présenter au
parlement est en tout point conforme aux
engagements qui ont été pris par le
président de la république est en tout
point conforme aux engagements qui ont
été pris par les parlementaires de la
majorité
universalité équité l'âge légal
demeurera à 62 ans et nous verrons
comment il est possible d'inciter les
français à travailler plus longtemps
neuf pour faire en sorte que les
retraites soit assurée je vous remercie
dans liberté quelques secondes monsieur
le premier ministre votre retraite va
coûter votre réforme va coûter plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros et va se
traduire par une baisse du niveau de vie
de votre été ce n'est pas une
affirmation de posture merci merci
monsieur le produit 10 mesdames et
messieurs les ministres les prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu
mercredi 15 janvier à 15 heures
la science est suspendue elle soit
reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen de la
proposition de résolution d'application
de l'article 34-1 da constitution pour
dénoncer agir contre les violences
faites aux femmes en situation de
handicap
l'un séance est suspendue voilà pour
cette séance des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre
en direct et en intégralité sur
l'antenne de public sénat on a vu trois
sujets majeurs faire le jeu d'ailleurs
de plusieurs questions aujourd'hui tout
d'abord sur le dossier de la réforme des
retraites avec quatre questions au total
sur ce sujet vous venez d'entendre
d'ailleurs la quatrième à l'instant les
socialistes ont par exemple dénoncé le
fait que le projet du gouvernement
n'était pas aboutie demandant à
l'exécutif de le retirer
c'est laurent pietrasinski qui a répondu
en disant lorsque la loi aura été votée
nous serons en mesure de faire toutes
les simulations sur le nouveau système
des retraites
une phrase qui a provoqué l'indignation
de nombreux sénateurs notamment à gauche
on a entendu certains sur les beurs les
bancs du ps dire ce n'est pas sérieux et
demandé à nouveau le retrait du projet
de loi la droite à l'instant vient
également de critiquer ce projet de
réforme en disant qu'il fallait se
concentrer d'abord sur le financement du
système
vous avez mis la charrue avant les
boeufs c'est le premier ministre qui lui
a répondu à l'instant le premier quart
dit qu'il n'y aurait plus de régimes
spéciaux et qui a dénoncé un les
postures politiques des personnes qui
critiquaient cette réforme
deuxième sujet avec beaucoup de
questions là encore sur l' escalade des
tensions entre l'iran et les états unis
on a compté à nouveau quatre questions
sur ce sujet aujourd'hui et on a entendu
un mehdi de montchalin la secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes
renvoyé dos-à-dos l'iran et les états
unis parlant de mauvaises décisions de
la part et d'autre et à l'annoncé un
conseil européen des ministres affaires
étrangères à bruxelles vendredi afin je
cite de regarder la situation et de voir
ce que l'on peut faire pour peser enfin
dernier sujet qui a été l'hôte aussi à
l'occasion de moments forts dans
l'hémicycle lorsque l'on a évoqué le
meurtre de sarah halimi en 2017 et cette
décision de la cour d'appel en décembre
dernier de dire que le meurtrier présumé
de sa realini de le déclaré pénalement
irresponsable
edouard philippe et la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet ont chacun redit leurs
émotions fortes et rappelé que les
magistrats avaient retenu la
circonstance aggravante de
l'antisémitisme mais le gouvernement n'a
pas voulu commenter davantage la
décision de la justice a rappelé que la
cour de cassation avait été saisie
voilà pour les trois moments forts
aujourd'hui de cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup
quentin pour toutes ces explications et
vous nous avez parlé à l'instant
notamment ya parmi les thématiques de
celle des retraites qui bien sûr a
permis de terminer l'année 2019 et qui
est aussi la première thématique de 2020
et mélisa pas ce qui vous est toujours
avec nous assez étonnant cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
c'est terminé et bien sûr cette réponse
ceux d'edouard philippe il avait répondu
à une question en début de séance et il
l'a encore terminée il avait besoin
qu'on y apporte aussi la contradiction
pour venir défendre son projet de loi
oui c'est vrai qu'il avait une réaction
il était beaucoup plus véhéments est
beaucoup plus à défendre le projet alors
ce qui est intéressant de noter qu'il a
parlé d' incitation à travailler plus
longtemps donc ça peut être peut être un
indice sur des modulations des
aménagements qui pourraient être donnés
sur l'âge pivot
on a parlé à un moment donné à madonna
lui c'est ça pour la cantate pour mais
plutôt quand on va plus loin on aurait
un bonus sur sa retraite c'est peut-être
des indices qu'il lâcherait enfin
peut-être sur cet âge pivot parce qu'il
a bien redit on changera pas l'âge à 62
ans de la retraite donc peut-être que
c'est des indices qui qu'il assouplirait
mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu l'impression
qu'ils voulaient défendre mais ça vient
un peu tard toutes les mesures de
justice sociale dont il a parlé pour
défendre cette réforme
elle arrive tardivement elles sont pas
très audible ils ont essayé pendant les
avant les fêtes de défendre les minimum
de retraite les pensions pour les femmes
avec plusieurs enfants
ça n'a pas tellement eu d'impact et puis
il ya un autre point sur les régimes
spéciaux la fin des régimes spéciaux
on a envie de dire mais qui nous
explique réellement parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de concessions faites à de
nombreuses professions une dizaine à la
louche
combien ça va coûter et ça représente
quand même des régimes alors on va plus
dire spéciaux on va dire particulier est
ce que c'est la rhétorique on a du mal à
le croire il n'ya pas de données
factuelles à ce qu'il dit parce qu'on a
toujours pas le projet de loi sous les
yeux et on a du mal à le croire encore
pierre laurent nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau un sénateur communiste de paris
bonjour pierre à laurent qu'avez vous
pensez bien de cette séquence avec ce
partage de paroles sur la question des
retraites notamment entre edouard
philippe et puis le sécrétaire d'état
laurent pietrasinski et edouard philippe
effectivement il ya peut-être une petite
modulation sur la question de bad
incitations à travailler plus longtemps
mais il n'a plus été question du malus
dans sa dernière prise de parole non moi
j'ai pas du tout entendu une modulation
dans son discours au contraire même j'ai
été frappé par le fait qu'ils aient
choisi comme thème de sa réponse la
nécessité de reculer l'âge de départ
est ce que en fait c'est là dessus qu'il
a argumenté donc qui vient maintenant
très clairement sur un objectif qui
avait été au départ un peu masquées par
toute la rhétorique sur le régime
universel
ensuite il ya eu la shps niveau qui a
été qui a mis sur la table ce sujet là
et aujourd'hui ce qui l'a clairement
confirmé c'est que un des objectifs
majeurs de la réforme est de reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite
or c'est là dessus et sur la question du
niveau des pensions que la colère est
très grande dans le pays
donc quand le gouvernement sort du flou
qu'il entretient bien on s'aperçoit avec
clarté que les deux objectifs principaux
de la réforme vise en fait à reculer
l'âge de départ est en vérité à baisser
le niveau des pensions
mais justement va demander à son idéal
entre états est cliqué au micro
d'alexandre poussard salle des
conférences
est ce que vous avez entendu ce que nous
a dit pierre laurent pour lui
bien on y voit clair dans le jeu du
gouvernement la réforme des retraites
elle a pour objectif de travailler plus
longtemps de reculer l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite est bien de baisser
le niveau des pensions
et oui laurent pietra chez free est ce
que cette réforme des retraites
représente un progrès pour les français
et ce qu'elle ne va pas baisser le
niveau des pensions pour une majorité de
français
cet apport noah c'est une réforme
sociale elle vise à s'occuper de ceux
qui sont les oubliés du dispositif
d'aujourd'hui elle va permettre de mieux
indemniser deux des meilleurs niveaux de
pensions aux 40 % des retraités les plus
vulnérables ceux qui ont moins de 1400
euros de pension par mois donc oui c'est
une belle réforme
c'est une réforme sociale donc vous
l'assurer pour une majorité de français
les pensions de retraite ne vont pas
baisser
l'enjeu n'est pas de faire baisser les
pensions de retraite on n'est pas dans
une dynamique budgétaire
d'ailleurs sur le fond quant au
gouvernement a annoncé qu' il qu'on
continuera à consacrer 14% du produit
intérieur brut donc d'autre richesse
nationale pour les retraites
c'était aussi pour montrer qu'il n'y
avait pas là d'ambition budgétaires de
réduction mais au contraire une ambition
dynamique je rappelle que la richesse
nationale progresse tous les ans et donc
la part de 14 pour cent vingt progressé
aussi mais aussi cette enveloppe reste
constant to progress un petit peu il ya
quand même une redistribution et pour
une partie de france de français pour la
classe moyenne laisse que les pensions
ne vont pas baisser
est ce que c'est une réforme qui va être
distribué oui elle va être distributif
d'ailleurs nous assumons 4e distributive
aller redistributif vis-à-vis des
oubliés je voulais dit du dispositif
actuel
on a un dispositif qui a été pensé et
construit sur l'après guerre il a été
pensé construire une période où les
parcours professionnels consiste à
rentrer relativement tôt dans une
entreprise y faire toute sa carrière il
a été pensé une période où la vie la
société
la composition des familles c'était
plutôt trois enfants et tôt dans la vie
du couple plutôt que deux et un peu plus
tard a été pensé à un moment donné où
les femmes on était peu en activité et
c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
donc tout cela fait que le système
actuel n'est plus adaptée ni à la
réalité du monde du travail
arrêtez de la société et il a vécu il a
été performant pour sa part il faut
maintenant le rénover en profondeur pour
constitué notre socle de solidarité
alors il ya eu un débat au sénat hier
sur cette réforme des retraites vous
avez fait vos premiers pas au sénat du
côté du gouvernement
mais les sénateurs sont assez mécontents
ils ont dénoncé des réponses floues un
manque de précision il parle même
d'amateurisme d'incompétence qu'est ce
que vous leur répondez sur ce fou à
écouter pour ce qui est des questions
des sénateurs
il leur appartient de les poser les
questions qu'ils souhaitent quand il
pose des questions pour avoir des
réponses précises on leur répond sur le
même niveau de précision
moi quand ils sont sur des questions au
générique on répond sur un niveau
génériques
il est évident que lorsque on attend des
réponses qui sont liées au projet de loi
que le projet de loi n'est pas encore
déposé
on a du mal à obtenir une réponse kallio
projet doit puisqu'on attend qu'il soit
déposé fin mai pourtant ce texte il est
écrit il envoyé aux conseils donnés dès
que le texte sera déposé sur le bureau
des assemblées on pourra en parler
concrètement très bien merci beaucoup le
empiétera chef qui pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre et nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau également le
plaisir d'accueillir claude malhuret
bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
indépendants de laillé vous êtes
également le président du groupe les
indépendants au sénat également avec nos
olivier paccaud bonjour sénateurs les
républicains de l'oise
claude malhuret d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure et bien vous avez été parmi les
premiers à interpeller le gouvernement
sur et bien la réforme des retraites au
coeur de vous de votre interrogation il
y avait la question de l' équilibre du
système
est-ce que vous avez été rassuré par la
réponse du coup c'est difficile de les
rassurer ou pas rassurés puisque tout va
dépendre des discussions qui vont avoir
lieu notamment vendredi c'est un c'est
un jour capitale c'est un jour de vérité
voilà depuis le début
edouard philippe de ce point de vue là
je crois qu'il faut lui en rendre acte
lui en donner acte insiste sur le fait
qu' on ne saura pas le système on ne le
prolongera pas si on n'a pas un
équilibre j'entends parler de réformes
systémiques ou de réforme paramétrique
moi je trouve que c'est quelqu'un sait
quelque chose de très rhétorique le
problème c'est que l' équilibre doit
être à long terme et les équilibres de
tête à court terme paramétrique mans et
systématique mais systémiquement par
conséquent je pense que cette querelle
sur le systémique et parametric ce qui
compte
voilà ce qui compte moi je sois l'âge
pivot que le soin comme dans tous les
pays européens où presse que
l'augmentation de l'âge de la retraite
ou que ce soit la conférence de
financement et aux autres idées ça c'est
des modalités je crois que ce qui compte
essentiellement c'est de dire c'est
destiné à arriver à l'équilibré à court
terme comme à long terme parce que c'est
la seule chance de survie ou la seule
façon de faire surveiller le système
dans le temps olivier pas quoi je vous
donne la parole dans un instant mais on
va tout de suite rejoindre alexandre
plus arsala des conférences
puisqu'alexandre vous êtes avec marc
fesneau le ministre des relations avec
le parlement et qui a d'ailleurs annoncé
en début de semaine que le texte de la
réforme des retraites avait bien été
envoyée au conseil d'état et oui on va
parler de cette méthode du gouvernement
pour mener cette réforme des retraites
effectivement vous avez annoncé l'envoi
du projet de loi écrit au conseil d'état
on a l'impression que le gouvernement
veut aller assez vite sur l'examen de ce
texte au parlement et dans un même temps
et bien la discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux et le gouvernement
est bien elle prend du temps elle n'est
pas du tout abouti il ya deux vitesses
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
situation mais enfin je suis désolé
d'avoir à rappeler ce que sont les
procédures quand vous dites vous avez la
volonté déposé un projet de loi en
conseil des ministres où devait le
transmettre au conseil d'état c'est la
légistique pardonnez moi de le dire de
base
je suis étonné que certains s'en
étonnent c'est à chaque fois que vous
avez un texte vous le transmettez
conseil d'état qui se saisit par
ailleurs d autres organisations
par exemple ici les casses les caisses
de retraite qui doivent se saisir et
donner émettre un avis par ailleurs
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un projet de
loi il ya un débat au parlement qui va
se saisir de la question à l'assemblée
nationale puis au sénat à l'assemblée
nationale en février au sénat en avril
qui permettra de nourrir d'améliorer par
la voie d'amendement un certain nombre
de dispositions qui sont aussi le fruit
du dialogue que nous avons voulu
construire avec les syndicats afin de
dire on est dans une méthode on peut pas
nous reprocher à la fois il ya six ou
huit mois de ne pas écouter de ne pas
vouloir dialoguer quand on dialogue me
dire vous dialoguez donc c'est pas prêt
il ya un certain nombre de principes qui
ont été posées par le premier ministre
et le président de la république
l'universalité le principe d'équité
principe de responsabilité
responsabilités égales comment on
finance les choses ça ce que ça veut
dire la responsabilité parce que nous
essayons de proposer des modifications
de la loi et des réformes profondes qui
soient financés sinon ça n'est pas
responsable ce n'est pas financé il ya
des discussions entre les syndicats il y
aura des discussions avec les
parlementaires et c'est le c'est un
travail ça en font en démocratie mais
quand vous expliquer que ces discussions
avec les syndicats prennent autant
autant de temps alors qu'il ya déjà eu
plus de deux ans de travail pour un
premier élément c'était de faire le
diagnostic de ce qu'étaient les 40
d'origine de ce qu'ils avaient comme
défaut de ce qu'étaient les difficultés
des uns et des autres regardez les
mécanismes de transition qui pourrait
être non pas s'il ya eu un travail
exploratoire un travail d'expertisé qui
a produit le rapport que vous connaissez
et qui a produit après des propositions
que vous connaissez et une fois qu'il ya
des propositions on dialogue on est dans
un processus qui me paraît pardon de le
dire normal donc que d'après qu'il ya
des disputes que d'y et des dialogues et
les syndicats qui soit plus ou moins
facile que les syndicats qui portent
plutôt l'idée de cette réforme va y
avoir des éclaircissements soient sur un
certain nombre de points d accord et que
c'est le débat démocratique
c'est très bien ainsi et donc c'est pas
s'étonner de tout ça alors justement il
ya une réunion avec les syndicats pour
une future réforme
une future pardon conférence de
financement sur le régime des retraites
est-ce que le gouvernement va mettre fin
à cette mesure de l'âge pivot à 64 ans
pour aller vers cette conférence le
premier ministre dans sa déclaration au
conseil économique et social et
environnemental a dit la chose suivante
il a dit comme nous sommes des êtres
responsables des responsables publics
responsable nous avons décidé de dire
qu'il fallait donner les voies et moyens
du financement et notre proposition
s'est inscrite au tour de la question
l'âge pivot en gros de dire il faut
travailler un peu plus longtemps comme
le font tous les pays européens qui ont
travaillé sur la question des retraites
et de l'équilibré des retraites
dans le même temps le premier ministre a
dit pour moi ce et nous semble que pour
nous c'est la solution mais si les
partenaires sociaux sont capables de
nous dire il ya d'autres solutions et
d'autres voies envisageables
on regardera et on prendra bon et donc
jusqu alors les par un certain de
partenaires sociaux qu'il n'y a pas la
question du financement on en parle à un
autre jour moi je suis assez content de
voir que un certain nombre de
partenaires sociaux que juge comme
responsable on dit il ya un sujet de
financement et donc jeu pour nous
proposons une conférence du financement
mais la conférence du financement ce
n'est pas la solution c'est le moyen et
donc la cheville von c'est le moyen
qu'ont proco le l'outil et qu'on propose
pour clarifier la question du
financement corporatif que la conférence
du financement nous disent par quelles
voies et moyens
elle entend aboutir à l' équilibre du
système très bien social que ça très
bien merci beaucoup a certes fait nous
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre olivier paccaud
est-ce que vous avez été convaincue par
les explications à l'instant de marc
fesneau qui a notamment a tenté de
justifier bien la méthode du
gouvernement
et puis aussi sa porte ouverte à la
conférence de financement je confesse
que non les choses étaient flous elle
reste flou pour un problème qui est à la
fois complexe mais très simple très
simple parce que il ya des données qui
sont démographique et mathématiques que
nous on ne peut pas nier complexe parce
que quasiment chaque cas individuel et
pour chaque français et c'est un cas
particulier
alors avoir voulu lancer une réforme
systémique me semble déjà une mauvaise
idée
sur le fond alors rendre le système plus
équitable ok vouloir réhausser les plus
basses pensions qui peut être contre
néanmoins au fur et à mesure où on
découvrait certaines particularités de
la réforme le mécontentement la crainte
n'a cessé d'augmenter au sein de la
population alors ça peut être parmi les
fonctionnaires notamment quand on leur a
dit qu'il allait avoir
leur carrière total pris en compte pour
le calcul et bien non plus les six
derniers mois
ensuite tout à l'heure il ya eu une
stella première réponse du secrétaire
d'état en charge des retraites
concernant le simulateur alors ça ça
valait son pesant d'or
en nous disant que de toute façon ce
simulateur ne sera efficace que lorsque
la loi serait votée alors comment voulez
vous qu'une population accepte quelque
chose qui est non pas clair obscur mais
c'est d'un flou non pas artistiques
l'info politique totale erreur de
méthode et à dernière chose quand même
ce qui me semble le plus gênant ce sont
les contradictions entre les messages
présidentiels
rodez qui a été donc re cité à plusieurs
reprises le premier ministre jean-paul
delevoye
on sait pas où on va c'est très malsain
et le résultat c'est qu'on est à 35
jours de grève dont la légitimité des
fois et peut être sujette à caution
mais quand même il ya un mécontentement
un malaise très profond dans le pays
oui un cafouillage en cas de tonneau
explique olivier paccaud vous êtes
d'accord et a mis la patte ski c'est ce
qui explique aussi que pour l'instant
même si le soutien de la population
baisse un petit peu il reste
majoritairement pour pour être contre la
réforme des retraites un oui moi je
pense que je suis assez d'accord avec
vous c'est qu'il ya un contraste énorme
entre le flou autour de ceux de ce
projet de loi de cette réforme et la
clarté du texte qui a envoyé au conseil
d'état donc c'est difficile de pouvoir
se dire on a encore du mou pour négocier
et se concerter alors qu'il ya déjà un
texte arrêté qui conduit mais on sent
bien que le gouvernement ait envie
d'aller très vite et procédés moi je
pense à l'inversé de ce que disais à
l'instant c'est que il ya trop
d'objectifs dans cette réforme est l'un
des objectifs n'avaient pas été si
clairement affiché au départ celui de l'
équilibre financier il a été relancé par
edouard philippe
il est clairement rejetée par les
français qui ne comprennent pas pourquoi
on leur impose ça donc c'est l'âge pivot
de reculer l'âge de la retraite et qui
le rejette les syndicats le rejette il
ya quand même d'autres solutions ce que
vous êtes vous dit c'est démographique
c'est mathématiquement on doit repousser
c'est pas ce que disent les syndicats et
c'est parce que font les syndicats sur
d'autres fonds comme agirc arrco il
arrive à moduler évidemment pas
expliquer ça c'est très compliqué en
tournée m larhant 300 centres les
cotisations
il ya énormément d'éléments et c'est un
travail pas de magicien mais en tout cas
d'équilibriste et c'est possible de le
faire seul ou comment il faut faire
confiance aux syndicats on a du mal à
croire que cette fameuse conférence de
financement n'est pas juste là pour
faire un petit peu diversion et faire
durer les choses pour qu'on oublie un
petit peu les problématiques et que
vraiment le gouvernement veut miser sur
les syndicats et un travail collaboratif
ou même les laisser prendre la main pour
faire cette gouvernance et cet équilibre
y compris la gouvernance pour la valeur
du point qui sera fixée après il faut
bien une gouvernance donc il ya ces
éléments là on a du mal à y voir clair
sur la véritable volonté travailler que
des syndicats en tout cas tout à l'heure
lors de la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement edouard
philippe à lorsque vous lui avez posé la
question claude malhuret d'ailleurs a à
nouveau mis l'accent sur le fait qu'il
voulait un système équilibré
on l'écouté je vous fait réagir notre
objectif monsieur le président malgré
ces de créer un système universel
universel équitable et responsable
un système universel c'est à dire que
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français quelle que soit leur profession
leur métier auront les mêmes droits et
seront soumis aux mêmes contraintes et 7
et c'est un élément de justice et
d'efficacité
c'est même un élément d'adaptation au
monde tel qu'il se transforme
car de plus en plus les carrières
professionnelles sont variées et
diverses telles personnes qui un jour
est fonctionnaire devient salarié puis
ensuite indépendant nous savons que les
carrières professionnelles sont hachées
nous savons qu'elles sont diverses
un système universel une réforme de
justice sociale
c'est ce qu'a fait valoir le premier
ministre tout à l'heure j'ai imaginé
pierre laurent que cela ne vous a pas
convaincu non mais non pas du tout parce
que on entend beaucoup de déclarations
de principe mais des couronnes dans le
concret on a autre chose
bon sur l'âge pivot par exemple c'est
très clair maintenant marc fesneau le
dis de manière très explicite lâche
pigot figure en toutes lettres dans le
projet de loi qui est transmis au
conseil d'état
donc on va nous demander de voter en
mars au parlement un projet de loi dans
lequel figurent l'âge pivot que tous les
syndicats sans aucun d'exception refuse
c'est la fête à préparer normalement et
on va et on va nous dire mais il y aura
plus tard une conférence de financement
et puis s'il ya des alternatives à sare
mais pourquoi ne pas ouvrir maintenant
le débat sur les alternatives puisqu'il
ya contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement
il ya des alternatives sur la table
proposés par les différents syndicats et
c'est ce débat là que le gouvernement
refuse d'ouvrir
parce que là aussi excusez moi de le
dire comme ça marque fait nous fait
beaucoup de baratin sur la méthode
mais depuis deux ans pourquoi est ce
qu'on arrive à une situation de blocage
où aucun syndicat ne veut donner son
aval au projet actuel parce que depuis
deux ans toutes les propositions qui ont
été mis sur la table ne sont pas écoutés
par le gouvernement par exemple sur les
recettes on nous parle du financement et
on nous parle d' équilibre tout le monde
vole équilibre du régime
bien sûr il a commencé par les syndicats
qui gèrent eux mêmes ces régimes par
répartition
donc tout le monde l équilibre mais
parlons recette est ce que là
l'objectif d'égalité salariale femmes
hommes dont toutes les études montrent
qu'ils rapporteraient 11 milliards
d'euros de recettes s'il était appliqué
est ce que ça fait partie des recettes
qui sont comptés ou pas dans le projet
de financement qui est sur la table
qui aujourd'hui peut répondre à cette
question est ce que ça fait partie ou
non de ce qu'on compte on serait pas les
exonérations de cotisations sociales ont
lié à un problème de recettes
est ce qu'elles sont efficaces pour
créer de l'emploi qui générera des
recettes
il ya quand même un débat sur cette
question il ya eu une grande enquête
récemment sur le cicr sur une grande
chaîne de télévision qui était quand
même assez explicite sur l'inefficacité
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire d'un
certain nombre d'exonérations de
cotisations sociales
cette question est sur la table est ce
que le gouvernement est prêt à ouvrir le
débat sur ça on l'a on nous dit tous ces
débats là on les aura pas faut voter le
projet de loi que dont personne ne veut
et puis ensuite on verra le reste en
vérité on verra rien du tout on verra
rien du tout ils appliqueront ce projet
de loi et c'est cette méthode là et le
faux tout ce qui est proposé qui est
rejeté dans le pays
le gouvernement peut demain que choisir
le passage en force mais s'il le fait la
crise sociale savs arbres que de manière
est ce un passage en force
oui je sais pas si c'est un passage en
forme je suis pas gouvernement et c'est
lui qui est premier ministre calin
manuel président de la république donc
ça c'est c'est leur problème mais
j'écoute avec attention
l'argument selon lequel il y à d'autres
l'autre moyen possibilité je vous écoute
avec attention mais je ne vous crois pas
bien entendu d'abord on dit les français
sont réticents les français sont contre
et c est ce que vous savez déjà vu
quiconque à qui on dit vouloir
travailler un an ou deux plus être
content ces cas sont plutôt pour leur
régime universel enfin l'universalité
oui à l'effort mais ils ont globalement
pour tous au flash pivot d'ex aequo le
signale aussi oui je suis la parole qui
sont après mais c'est aussi des étapes
je suis je pense que c'est je pense que
c est une partie du problème puisque je
veux bien qu'on soit les plus
intelligents on est toujours les plus
intelligents on a le meilleur système de
retraite au monde d'ailleurs on se
demande pourquoi les autres ne vont pas
emprunter 6 millions au monde on est les
plus intelligents donc on va trouver des
solutions
moi je constate que toutes les grandes
démocraties qui ne kiffe qui sont autour
de nous qui ont les mêmes espérances de
vie qui montrent qu'ils ont le même
problème de ratio entre les retraités
les actifs ont toutes trouvé qu'elle
soit de droit de des gouvernements de
droite de gauche ont tous trouvé une
seule solution parmi avec d'autres
annexes bien entendu mais une solution
c'est de travailler plus longtemps
aujourd'hui les seuls qui sont en train
d'essayer de vouloir revenir vers ses
les italiens qui sont 67 parce que di
maio émouvant 5 étoiles fait de la
démagogie et est en train de proposer
aux 62 mais ils sont tous à 65 et à 67
jusqu'à présent pour l'italie je pense
que dans ces conditions et compte
pousser toute l'europe décide de
renoncer au progrès social alors quoi
faire
oui mais il se trouve que c'est suivi on
n'aurait jamais fait la sécurité sociale
on n'aurait rien fait 45 et bien sûr
tous les autres pays d'europe pour la
sécurité sociale de beveridge à à
bismarck et caetera et ils ont tous eu à
assurer la sécurité cela souvent avant
nous donc quand je compare aux autres
pays d'europe je compare des choses qui
sont comparables et en général et ce
qu'elle soit ne serait-ce que l'emploi
en allemagne on peut pas dire qu'on a
les mêmes emplois et on a notamment au
niveau des seniors donc c'est bien beau
de vouloir reculer l'âge de la retraite
mais il faut aussi que les seniors
soient souhaité en entreprise pour le
moment ce n'est pas le bienvenu tout
particulièrement du problème en
allemagne des retraités le niveau de vie
des retraités n'est pas tout à fait le
même je pense que le nôtre qui est déjà
alarmant parce qu'ils sont plus en plus
précaire parce qu'il ya un sérieux
problème de chômage entre 60 et 64 ans
on n'a pas tout à fait les mêmes on ne
peut pas se comparer tout le temps aux
autres pays européens mais je suis
d'accord je pense que on a une
philosophie un adn en france on a décidé
de le garder là on est en train de les
mines était de se dire bon bah
finalement on va s'aligner par amour aux
autres c'est pas très grave
le buzz propositions je crois du pcc la
retraite à 60 ans c'est toujours le
retour de l'entente vous pensez que
c'est crédible mais vous savez les
français pour qu'ils arrivent à l'âge de
la retraite actuel on travaille on vous
vous connaissez le chiffre non il ya une
proportion très importante de la
population qui n'est plus au travail
depuis déjà plusieurs années quand elle
arrive quand elles arrivent à la
retraite
oui bien sûr donc est notamment allé
tous les régimes spéciaux et notamment
les handicapés
ne pas continuer à repousser l'âge de la
retraite en mettant en situation de
précarité de plus en plus de salariés
dans cette période qui va entre 55 ans
et 60 et 64 ans n'est pas une idée
saugrenue comme vous avez garé de le
dire c'est une idée qui au contraire
mériterait d'ailleurs at elle c'est elle
à tel point c'est une idée sérieuse que
le gouvernement a été obligé obligé de
dire que la question de l'emploi des
seniors devait être un des sujets de la
négociation mais le problème c'est que
cette négociation elle n'aura pas lieu
avant l'écriture du projet de loi et
c'est vrai sur tous les sujets on les
prend un par un en vérité à au lieu
d'ouvrir le débat et la négociation avec
des alternatives possibles
le gouvernement a bouclé en vérité le
projet de loi dont les faits avant il
souhaite d'ici juin derniers mois puis
on va passer à un autre sujet oui alors
effectivement il ya quand même une
évolution dans dans le débat sur les
retraites actuellement c'est que
désormais se polarise sur la question de
l' équilibre financier et c'était la
moindre des choses quand même et la
première erreur du gouvernement à mon
avis c'est de n'être pas parti sur la
nécessité d'équilibrer ce système alors
on a des analyses différentes
pierre laurent pense qu'effectivement on
peu l'équilibré en allant chercher
d'autres sources de financement jeu pas
forcément sur cette ligne là moi je
pense que comme l'a dit claude malhuret
il faudra travailler un petit peu plus
mais pas forcément en se basant sur un
hp vous il ya d'autres critères alors en
nombre de trimestres outre toujours est
il que on a eu à travers la méthode du
gouvernement une un bon résumé de du
fait que le coup de baguette magique du
nouveau monde qui croyait que on pouvait
être faire table rase du passé de tout
ce qui existait ça ne marche pas du tout
et ce qui m'a frappé je termine là
dessus dans la déclaration dans une
déclaration du premier ministre tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il nous a dit que notre
système actuel était un des meilleurs du
monde
alors pourquoi vouloir le changer c'est
bourré de paradoxes de contradictions ça
sera donc le mot la phase sur ce thème
on va passer un deuxième sujet qui a
également marqué les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
et rejoindre alexandre poussard vous
êtes avec ronan le gleut pour sénateurs
les républicains pour parler de la
montée de tension entre l'iran et les
états unis
et oui ronan le gleut dans un quart
d'heure le président américain donald
trump veut faire une conférence de
presse pour répondre à l' attaque
iranienne des bases américaines en
irak qu'est ce que vous attendez du
président américain j'attends tout
d'abord qu'il nous dise précisément ce
qu'il s'est passé puisque ils vont tirer
un bilan de la situation nous dire
précisément quels ont été les zones
ciblées et qu'elle a été et quelle a été
leur impact précis et puis d'autre part
j'attends du président trump qu'il nous
dise sa vision à long terme parce que on
voit bien dans sa diplomatie en dents de
scie qu'il est difficile de comprendre
quelle est la vision à long terme on
voit une vision à court terme des
réactions qui s'enchaînent il est plus
difficile de voir où il veut vraiment
revenir sur le long terme et c'est ça
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on peut dire que donald trump
est responsable de cette escalade de
violence avec l'iran qui dure depuis
quelques années non je ne partage pas
cette opinion parce que il faut revenir
à la base du problème aujourd'hui là
l'enjeu principal c'est la désescalade
et c'est surtout la non prolifération
nucléaire il ne faut pas que l'iran se
dote de l'arme nucléaire et c'est ça le
point de départ et donc il ya cet accord
qu'on appelle jace ipo est signé à
vienne en 2015 et qu'il y avait cet
objectif empêcher l'iran de se doter de
l'armé nucléaire il faut pas oublier le
point de départ voilà et c'est cet
objectif là qui est partagé par la
france bien évidemment mais qui est
aussi l'objectif du président trump est
un objectif qu'il faut maintenir et on
vous parliez de cette diplomatie
américaine en donne ci est ce que la
france doit prendre ses distances
vis-à-vis son ailier américain qui
déstabilise le moyen-orient alors la
france est membre permanent à part
entière de l'otan et à ce titre là nous
sommes les alliés des américains
et puis rappelons quand même que la
question fondamentale pour la france
c'est la lutte la guerre contre
l'islamisme radical contre le terrorisme
islamiste
les attentats du bataclan ont été
coordonnées organisées depuis jaca en
syrie et c'est une coalition
internationale dont la france faisait
partie avec des pilotes de rafale qui
partait de jordanie de la base aérienne
projetée en jordanie je me suis rendu
j'ai discuté avec nos nos chasseurs nos
militaires sur place en jordanie et avec
dans une coalition internationale avec
les américains et nous avons les
etats-unis nous et nos partenaires de
cette coalition internationale fait
tomber la capitale de l'état islamique à
jaca qui est une grande victoire puisque
c'est de l'ain comme je le disais que
son parti organisé les attentats du
bataclan donc c'est dans ce contexte là
que s'inscrit notre démarche et notre
présence militaire en jordanie en irak
en syrie travers donc il faut conserver
notre alliance avec les etats-unis pour
conserver cette coalition internationale
merci beaucoup
prenons le voulez pour votre réaction
natif de sécurité 1 qui préside à la
position actuelle de la france
pierre laurent vous avez interrogé tout
à l'heure le gouvernement sur la
situation et sur la montée de tension
entre l'iran et les etats-unis
qu'avaient que pensez vous de la
position de la france qui effectivement
est dans une position compliquée elle ne
peut pas dénoncer son allié elle appelle
en même temps à la désescalade de la
tension
je n'ai pas été du tout rassuré
satisfait de la réponse de la ministre
qui dit deux choses totalement
contradictoire parce que si on veut la
désescalade
il faut cesser de tenir des propos
qu'ils soient des propos indulgent à
l'égard de ce café donald trump
parce que l'attak l'assassinât ciblé de
soliman ni ce qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'être un grand analysent pour
comprendre que c'est l'engrenage de la
guerre qui est décidé avec cette mesure
là comme l'avait été précédemment la
dénonciation par les états unis de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien enfin
le retrait des états unis de cet accord
donc on est dans un engrenage
extrêmement dangereux on a aujourd'hui
une escalade
évidemment dans laquelle liraud
s'engouffre qui est extrêmement
inquiétante avec un résultat au plus au
passage
et quand même un comble c'est qu'on
renforce le soutien populaire
un régime autoritaire on iront alors
même qu'ils avaient en irak en iran au
liban qui mouvement de protestation
populaire qui était prometteur
intéressant là on les relèguent au
second plan et on va vers une escalade
dangereuse donc moi je crois que la
france doit reprendre très vite son
autonomie politique
sa capacité d'initiative indépendante et
je ne sens pas du tout cela dans ce que
j'ai entendu du discours tout à l'heure
parce qu'on nous explique la ministre
nous a expliqué qu' on était solidaires
mais on n'était pas solidaire on était
solidaires de ça mais on n'était pas
solidaire de ça ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas
de sens on voit bien que les américains
seront 30 changer d'objectif dans la
région et nous nous sommes entraînés là
dedans si nous continuons à ne pas
vouloir prendre nos distances claude
manière à ce que vous êtes d'accord à ce
que la france va prendre une position
plus franches quand on le voit ce qui
est en jeu bien c'est aussi la lutte
contre des chaussettes aussi l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien sont des enjeux
sécuritaires najjar mondiaux oui je
pense que les
l'urgence n'est pas tellement celle de
l'autonomie
l'urgence est celle d'essayer de
contribuer à la désescalade
je crois que tout le monde deuxièmement
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on vous le
disait d'ailleurs vous même tout à
l'heure la france est dans le temps nous
avons des alliés
les alliés c'est pas toujours facile
winston churchill disait il ya qu'une
chose pire que de combattre avec des
alliés c'est de combattre sans eux on a
des alliés mais je tremble jusqu'à
preuve du contraire l'estonie sont des
alliés il est impulsif il a pas de
stratégie ou les on a peut-être une en
tout cas qu'on comprend pas les effets
contre-productifs mais en fait jusqu'à
preuve du contraire ce sont quand même
des alliés et franchement à choisir si
j'ai à choisir entre les etats-unis et
l'iran demain mon choix est à mon avis
le choix de plupart des européens va
être vite fait il faut quand même
rappeler et je dis pas ça pour justifier
l'acte de trump je suis d'accord avec
tout le monde pour dire que c'est
impulsif que c'est dangereux etc
mais il faut quand même rappeler que
l'iran est quand même le pays
le pays terroriste international depuis
78 qui a fait des milliers de victimes
que monsieur sulejmani assurent les sur
les mains des centaines de milliers de
victimes en irak en syrie au liban et
ailleurs et que par conséquent il faut
pas non plus dire dans cette danse est
que les états unis ont réagi à l'attaqué
de leur ambassade et de différentes
bases ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même beaucoup de choses que l'iran a
juré la destruction d'israël c'est le
seul pays musulman aujourd'hui qui
continue avec obsession et qui se dote
d'un programme nucléaire justement pour
et qui essaye justement pour arriver à
ses fins ça fait quand même beaucoup de
choses je note enfin que en définitive
lui depuis trois jours tout le monde
panique un petit peu mais que la riposte
on verra ce que dit rome tout à l'heure
mais que la réponse iranienne et on
décide en définitive à ces mesures et
ecclésiale est sont peut-être en train
de s'apercevoir d'une part qu' ils
risquent gros et d'autre part qu'ils ont
chez eux une contestation qui l'ont noyé
dans le sang mais qui pourrait bien
repartir une fois qu'ils auront oublié
les frappes deux amériques olivier
paccaud effectivement l'iran a fait
valoir que c'était une des représailles
modéré qui était proportionnée en tout
cas à l'attaqué avait reçu alors je
pense quand même que vu de france faut
pas oublier une chose c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'un côté soi-disant le faucon
américains et de l'autre la colombe
iranienne c'est pas du tout ça est que
monsieur sur les manies effectivement
c'était pas le mahatma gandhi où le
dalaï lama
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec claude
malhuret donc ça les 110 il faut des as
mais il faut qu'il y ait une désescalade
c'est évident et les tweets épidermique
du président américain ne contribue
certainement pas à la sérénité du débat
c'est la moindre des choses
néanmoins et l'a peut-être que mes
propos je vais tenter de les mesurer
mais
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'a souligné claude malhuret à savoir
que l'iran ait ces derniers jours on a
encore entendu des appels à la
destruction d'israël on parle du grand
satan américain alors que ce sont deux
démocraties qui sont parmi nos alliés et
qui reste sur bien des points
des modèles dans le monde et la frappe
préventive
la frappe préventive elle peut être
utile elle peut être utile dans la
diplomatie en 36 bon je vais vous donner
des exemples très clair le vieil agrégé
d'histoire que je suis vous dis que si
en 36 lorsqu'il clair à remanier
remilitariser pardon la rhénanie si à ce
moment là les gouvernements français et
anglais étaient intervenus peut-être
qu'on n'aurait pas eu plus qu'une
escalade après il faut savoir des fois
frappé d'accord et ben on va passer un
dernier thème pour conclure cette
émission ce qui a lui aussi une
actualité forte cet après midi c'était
la conférence de presse de carlos ghosn
depuis beyrouth le récit d'alizée
janvier puis réaction juste après une
prise de parole très attendu est
millimétré carlos ghosn avait prévenu
pas un mot sur les conditions de sa
fuite rocambolesque depuis le japon
devant 150 journalistes l'ancien pdg a
d'abord voulu raconter sa version de la
fère et clamer son innocence
je suis ici pour laver mon honneur et
pour dire clairement une chose qui a été
interprété comme une hérésie dans le
système judiciaire japonais in japanese
judicial système ces accusations sont
fausses et je n'aurais jamais dû être
arrêté en premier lieu never been
arrested in the first place conférence
de presse fleuve pour dénoncer ses
conditions de détention
je n'ai pas échapper à la justice j'ai
fui l'injustice et la persécution la
persécution politique ayant duré plus de
400 jours de traitement inhumain dans un
système conçu pour me briser et ne
voulant pas me donner un minimum de
justice
je n'ai d'autre choix que de me protéger
et de protéger ma famille shaw russe ce
fut une décision difficile et un risque
que l'on ne prend que lorsqu'on est
résigné à l'impossibilité d'un procès
équitable
free zain possibility offertoires une
heure de discours pendant laquelle le
pdg a voulu régler ses comptes avec
nissan citant des noms montrant des
documents visant à prouver qu'il a été
la victime d'un complot ourdi par le
constructeur japonais au japon carlos
ghosn fait l'objet de plus
inculpation pour abus de confiance et
non déclaration de revenus votre analyse
emilie s'appelle ch'ti sur cette riposte
de carlos ghosn riposte de communication
où il a dit notamment je n'ai pas fui la
justice
j'ai échappé à l'injustice et la
persécution on passe du fugitif à la
victime clairement donc c'est quelqu'un
de très combatif qui veut faire passer
cette image de fuite il en a pas du tout
parlé pour cause puisqu'il a travaillé
quand même cette fuite manière assez
spéciale avec des malfrats
donc on voit bien que c'est une bataille
d'image pour relever la tête blanchir
son image comme il l'a dit ce qu on a du
mal quand même à comprendre enfin je
pense que c'est difficile à cet argument
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
travaillé quand même au japon donc
respecté qui a fait des affaires et qui
ne respectent pas la loi là bas alors
c'est quand même un pays démocratique
même s'il ya probablement des excès que
c'est pas du tout la même justice que la
nôtre puisqu'elle repose pas sur le
soupçon d'innocence enfin le l'innocence
la présomption d'innocence
donc c'est différent mais on a c'est
quand même une fuite s'est quand même
mais probablement ça va fonctionner
parce que le procès va s'attarder et on
aura probablement plus tôt cette image
là de victimes que l'image du fugitif
pierre laurent votre avis sur ce jeu là
je paye pas de ne pas écouter la
conférence de presse de carlos je vais
pas commenter sa conférence de presse
ce que je veux dire c'est que bon
évidemment ce qu'on aimerait d'abord
comprendre ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
au départ pour qu'un homme qui travaille
à la tête de renault nissan se retrouve
dans cette situation il s'est quand même
passé des choses
bon pour le moment le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'on n'y voit pas clair sur
ce qui s'est passé pour ensuite sur
toute la partie rocambolesque de ces
derniers jours bon ce qui est frappant
d'abord c'est que ce qui se passe c'est
quand même pas donné à tout le monde
dont 20 millions d'années à tout le
monde
voilà il dans des conditions qu'on
connaît pas encore totalement enfin faut
quand même un peu de moyens pour arriver
à faire ça et puis la mort au liban il a
l'air de pouvoir parler devant beaucoup
de monde tout ça il ya beaucoup de gens
qui dans le monde doit faire à la
justice qui aimerait pouvoir se défendre
entre guillemets aussi mal que ça craint
donc voilà maintenant ce qu'on aimerait
comprendre c'est à quoi s'est livrée
carlos ghosn
quand il était à la tête de renault
nissan pour en arriver là olivier
paccaud moi je serais très bref c'est
une histoire à braga abracadabrantesque
et ça fera je pense dans quelques années
l'objet d'un scénario d'un film
formidable ni plus ni moins claude
malhuret
j'avais la fin j'allais figra peu près
la même chose c'est à dire que je suis
comme tout le monde à battre et je pense
qu'il faudra des années pour que on
arrive à savoir un genre un jour qu'on
arrive à savoir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé un truc carlos ghosn et nissan
entre nissan gouvernement japonais entre
carlos ghosn et gore 1 en japonais
comment il a organisé sa fuite il faudra
des années et des années et pendant
toutes ces années on va avoir une très
bonne série netflix
grâce à vous et à toutes les chaînes
home voilà le début d'un bon scénario je
veux donc que c'était contre offensive
médiatique de carlos ghosn
merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ce premier débrief de 2020
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement à très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]